[Musique]
bonjour à tous il est 9h30 nous sommes
en direct sur l'antenne de Public Sénat
nous sommes au matin du 10e jour de
l'examen de la réforme des retraites au
Sénat un examen que vous suivez sur
notre antenne in extenso des heures de
direct pour tout suivre vous pouvez lire
d'ailleurs aussi un les articles de la
rédaction sur notre site c'est public
c'est nap.fr pour m'accompagner toute
cette journée de grand direct je suis en
compagnie d'Audrey vue etaz bonjour
Audrey vous êtes en tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle ou en sommes-nous Audrey il
reste au total environ 750 amendements
examiné on en est où exactement et bien
Quentin nous sommes à la fin de
l'article 10 sur les petites pensions
vous savez on parle de la fameuse
retraite à 1200 euros il reste quelques
amendements et puis on passera à
l'article 11 l'article 11 ça concerne
les stages je rappelle que dans le texte
il y a une vingtaine d'articles en tout
toute la question aujourd'hui est de
savoir si les choses vont s'accélérer
c'est en tout cas la volonté de la
majorité sénatoriale de droite et du
gouvernement qui veulent un vote sur le
texte final avant demain soir minuit oui
oui mais voilà ils ont un caillou dans
la chaussure et pas des moindres la
gauche sanatoriale qui a promis de tout
faire pour qu'il n'y ait pas de vote
dimanche soir à minuit elle a gauche qui
maintient aussi la pression car vous le
savez aujourd'hui il y a une grande
journée de mobilisation ça va maintenir
la pression dans la rue aussi et là je
vous dis hier dans l'hémicycle elle a
été très agitée comme tous les jours
maintenant depuis mardi Audrey mais on a
encore passé de nouvelles étapes on peut
le dire hier oui car le gouvernement a
déclenché l'article 44-3 l'arme ultime
pour contraindre les débats ça signifie
qu'il n'y aura qu'un vote à la fin avec
les seuls amendements retenus par le
gouvernement 70 sur le millier qu'il
restait à examiner la gauche vous
l'imaginez il y a eu des broncas dans
les rangs de la gauche elle estime qu'on
musel le Parlement mais elle a décidé de
continuer de sierger car même si ces
amendements ne seront pas retenus dans
le texte final elle a le droit de les
défendre pendant deux minutes un droit
qu'elle a pris alors les prises de
parole s'enchaînent depuis hier les
amendements sont défendus un à un c'est
une manière aussi de montrer qu'il y
avait du contenu dans ces amendements
c'est ce qu'on nous a dit dans les rangs
de la gauche c'est une manière aussi de
fustiger l'action du gouvernement
écoutez il y a aucune écoute de toute
une série d'amendements présentés par
nos collègues alors non seulement on
nous empêche de débattre non seulement
le président de la République le
parchemin les syndicats non seulement on
part des méthodes cumulatives parce que
c'est quand même rare de cumuler elle
fait qu'on puisse pas parler à
l'Assemblée nationale qu'on limite le
temps qu'on utilise le 44
alinéa 3 et en même temps
à mes prix profonds profond pour ce qui
est dit par nos collègues
la gauche qui s'est énervée aussi hier
soir à plusieurs reprises car la
Commission et la droite ont décidé de
retirer certains de leurs amendements
qui ne figuront pas dans le vote final
quoi de plus normal vous me direz mais
oui mais voilà quand on retire un
amendement ça enlève aussi des facto
tous les amendements qui lui étaient
reliés des fois il y en a des dizaines
des centaines qui appartiennent à la
gauche la gauche qui a estimé que c'est
une nouvelle manière de museler
l'opposition écoutez vous allez même
jusqu'à retirer certains de vos
amendements monsieur le rapporteur pour
nous empêcher de présenter nous sous
amendements alors ça si ça n'est pas
empêché le débat je ne sais pas comment
ça s'appelle depuis le début de
l'après-midi nous présentons nos
amendements nous sous amendements mais
nous n'avons aucune possibilité de
réagir de compléter de soutenir ou de
dire cela nous convient ou pas on est
véritablement là encore une fois dans un
déni de la démocratie un déni du rôle
essentiel du Parlement
vous le voyez Quentin les choses peuvent
finalement s'enflammer à tout moment
merci Audrey pour toutes ces
explications la séance vient de
reprendre c'est le président du Sénat
Gérard Larcher qui préside direction
l'hémicycle
notamment parce que le montant de la
retraite un droit individuel reflète que
les femmes ont plus souvent des
interruptions de carrière que des hommes
que les hommes pendant lesquels elles
ont interruption certes pas ou peu
cotiser mais pendant lesquels elles ont
effectué d'autres tâches souvent souvent
d'ailleurs pour permettre à l'homme de
se libérer et de poursuivre son parcours
professionnel je tiens à dire que les
retraites c'est un mécanisme qui est
insuffisamment mais qui est
redistributif et là on a effectivement
pour les femmes et bien ce mécanisme là
qui est qui n'agit pas quoi qui n'est
pas opérant donc le présent amendement a
pour objet de faire évoluer d'approche
comparative genre du comité de suivi des
retraites dans le cadre de son avis
annuel afin d'y intégrer une approche
par métier par métier donc qui sont ou
la discrimination et j'en ris
mais
de la commission monsieur le rapporteur
il y a déjà une analyse qui est faite au
niveau du Comité d'Orientation des
Retraites comités de suivi des retraites
donc la vie
l'allemandement est satisfait donc avis
défavorable au retrait
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente de la Commission de Madame et
Monsieur les rappeurs messieurs les
rapporteurs pour les mêmes raisons que
c'est l'évoquées par le rapporteur la
vie des favorable il est maintenu il est
retiré
alors nous allons examiner maintenant
huit amendements
en discussion commune et assuzamondement
d'autres sous amendements l'amendement
1979 madame billon merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la majoration de 10% de la
pension pour trois enfants ou plus a été
institué dès la création du régime
général par l'ordonnance du 19 octobre
1945 elle a été étendue aux artisans et
commerçants en 1972 l'objet de cet
amendement est détendent cette
majoration aux professionnels libéraux
et aux avocats si les professionnels
libéraux bénéficient de régime autonomes
adapté à leur spécificité
professionnelle ils ont bénéficié au fil
du temps de l'harmonisation progressive
des règles de leur régime de base avec
celle du régime général cette
harmonisation concerne notamment les
règles de durée d'assurance dépense les
pensions de réversion ou bien les
majorations de durée pour enfants pour
autant les professionnels libéraux et
les avocats ne bénéficient pas de la
majoration de 10% du montant de la
pension pour trois enfants ou plus or
vous en conviendrez c'est un dispositif
de solidarité essentiel dans le panorama
des droits familiaux de retraite la
Caisse nationale d'assurance vieillesse
des professions libérales demande
plusieurs depuis plusieurs années que
les professionnels libéraux bénéficient
également de ce dispositif donc je
propose que soit transposée cette
disposition en équité pour les départs
en retraite à compter du 1er septembre
2023 dans une logique d'harmonisation
monsieur le président
monsieur Cabanel merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues la majoration de 10% du
montant de la passion pour trois enfants
est un acquis social important dans
notre pays pour autant si les salariés
les artisans et les commerciaux
bénéficient de cette majoration les
professionnels libérales sont exclus de
ce dispositif le premier février dernier
devant la délégation droit des femmes de
l'Assemblée nationale monsieur le
ministre vous vous êtes dit ouvert à
avancer avec les parlementaires sur le
sujet dans la foulée le gouvernement est
plusieurs députés déposer des amendes de
main visant à éteindre la mâchoire de
10% de la pension pour trois enfants au
plus ou plus aux professeurs libérales
malheureusement les débats n'ont pas
permis leur examen anciences publiques
dans une démarche de remise à niveau de
la protection sociale des professions
libérales un autre amendement propose
d’étendre cette majoration
professionnelle libéraux et aux avocats
c'est une question d'équité il est en
effet injuste que ces professions soient
exclues de ce dispositif alors qu'il
contribue au financement de cet avantage
par le biais des cotisations
d'Allocations Familiales de la CSG et de
divers impôts dont ils s'acquittent
merci
à un moment 2311 madame meunier merci
monsieur
au collègues à ce des collègues
précédemment donc étant le bénéfice de
la majoration de 10 % à la pension aux
enfants professions avocates et avocat
il y a l'ensemble des professionnels des
professions libérales au préalable je
note que contrairement au projet de 2019
votre gouvernement monsieur le ministre
s'était engagé à ne pas toucher au
régime autonome de retraite des
professions libérales dont celui des
avocats la profession dont la
mobilisation fin de 2019 et début 2020
avait été historique le vit comme un
soulagement et nous pouvons que nous en
féliciter nous appelons là à étendre la
mobilisation à entendre la mobilisation
qui s'exprime actuellement chez celles
et ceux qui sont concernés le monde de
la justice vous le savez souffre
actuellement de sous-investissement de
délai de traitement interminable qui
mettent à mal les justiciers
démotive l'exercice de la défense c'est
donc dans ce contexte que je vous
propose d'adopter cet amendement
permettant d'aligner le régime des
majorations de pension
pour les parents de trois enfants et
plus cette majoration est assurée
financièrement par la Caisse
d'Allocations Familiales abondée par les
cotisations sociales des avocats et des
avocats qui pourtant ne peuvent
prétendre à cette majoration de pension
au lendemain de nos débats sur la
compensation des temps familiaux et
après avoir entendu le discours
défendant la valeur famille sur ses
bancs j'imagine que vous ne pourrez que
voter cet amendement financé par les
bénéficiaires à hauteur de 100 millions
d'euros par le biais des cotisations
familiales et la CSG d'un pot diverses
merci tout merci alors la vie de la
commission
parlons
1905 rectifié terre monsieur le
Président Patriat
monsieur le Président merci je serais
beaucoup plus Brest depuis que
l'amendement est similaire il vise à
temps donné aux professions libérales
l'avantage des 10% pour 3 enfants merci
Monsieur Cabanel merci monsieur le
Président c'est poursuit le même
objectif que la vente de main que j'ai
défendu précédemment il s'agit de
permettre aux professionnels libéraux de
bénéficier de la majoration de 10% du
montant de la passion pour trois enfants
opus elle est star de ce qui existe déjà
pour les salariés les artisans et les
commerçants
monsieur le monsieur le rapporteur
l'amendement
la Commission a été particulièrement
sensible à cette avancée c'était une
inégalité historique et qu'il fallait
compenser et c'est de réjouissant de
voir que l'ensemble des des bancs
partagent cette vision de donner 10% de
majoration supplémentaires pour le père
ou les mères il faut présenter d'abord
votre amendement
d'accord
j'ai deux minutes pour présenter mon
amendement monsieur le Président je
compte bien les utiliser et en
conséquence ça fait partie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais faire un rappel aux règlements
c'est
ça fait partie
ça fait partie ça fait partie de nos
marqueurs la dimension familiale
voyez-vous monsieur le ministre manquait
dans ce dispositif de retraite que vous
nous proposez parce que sont bien les
familles qui font que notre système
c'est l'équilibrera c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous étions sensibles à ce type
à ce type d'amélioration de même que
nous sommes sensibles à l'avancée à
travers la VPF ou lava et de même que
nous avons été particulièrement
mobilisés pour qu'il y ait une surcote
pour les maires de famille voilà c'est
marqueur famille sont essentiels merci
alors monsieur le ministre sous
amendement présenté par le gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président il s'agit
simplement par ce sous amendement
d'apporter une précision rédactionnelle
pour bien garantir le fait que parmi les
professions libérales concernées les
avocats sont intégrés de fait ils le
sont mais le Conseil National des
Barreaux nous avait dit son inquiétude
sur une formulation nous répondrons à
cette inquiétude pour clarifier le droit
et si vous me permettez monsieur le
Président tous les amendements vont dans
la même direction et répondre à cet
engagement qui a pris le gouvernement
dans le débat d'élargir l'accès la
majoration de 10% aux professions
libérales et donc le gouvernement
analyse favorable à l'amendement de
monsieur le rapporteur ainsi soit
demandé pour des questions légistiques
et demande le retrait des examens qui
poursuivent exactement le même objectif
mais la logistique nous amène à
privilégier celui de Monsieur Savary
merci un amendement 13006
il est défendu il est défendu
et un amendement
3409 madame ponce
oui merci monsieur le Président alors il
faut rappeler que la majoration de 10%
de la pension pour 3 enfants ou plus ça
a été institué dès la création du régime
général par l'ordonnance du 19 octobre
1945 elle a été étendue aux artisans et
commerçants en 1972 il s'agit ici de
proposer d'étendre cette majoration aux
professionnels professionnels libéraux
car si les professionnels libéraux ont
bénéficié au fil du temps effectivement
de l'harmonisation progressive des
règles de leur régime de base avec celle
du régime général notamment les règles
de durée d'assurance les pensions de
réversion les majorations de durée pour
enfants elles n'ont pas elles ne
bénéficie toujours pas de la majoration
de 10% du montant de la pension pour
trois enfants ou plus or c'est un
dispositif de redistribution horizontale
essentielle
la Caisse nationale d'assurance
vieillesse de cette profession le
demandait depuis plusieurs années elles
avaient raison
encore une fois l'absence de ce
dispositif pénalise majoritairement les
femmes donc c'est un amendement que nous
défendons d'autant plus que je rappelle
que par exemple pour le micro les
personnes les personnes qui 5 millions 8
personnes qui devaient bénéficier du
dispositif 80% étaient des femmes mais à
la fin celles qui bénéficient de la
revalorisation elle ne bénéficie qu'à
60% des femmes donc souvent on dit c'est
une le mycose c'est pour les femmes
puisque 60% sont bénéficiaires mais
elles étaient 80% pourtant à bénéficier
du myco et on voit bien que c'est une
mesure qui n'est en rien
favorable aux femmes elle atténue un
petit peu simplement les inégalités
merci
j'ai entendu la vie de la Commission
merci je vous demande de retirer les
amendements au profit du celui de la
commission 2161 sous amendé par le
gouvernement qui fait qui résume les
affaires et défavorables donc pour les
autres merci
la vie du gouvernement
et les favorable enfin favorables bien
sûr un son d'amendement et il avait
demandé le retrait très bien
sont-ils retirés
oui oui
d'accord merci
4 amendements
identiques au suites en discussion
commune un amendement 475 rectifiés par
présenté par Madame billon merci
monsieur le Président la loi du 9
novembre 2010 portant sur la réforme des
retraites proposaient que les indemnités
journalières versées dans le cadre des
congés maternité commencer après le 1er
janvier 2012 soit désormais pris en
compte dans le salaire de base jusqu'en
2017 ces indemnités journalières étaient
seulement prises en compte au titre de
la durée d'assurance requises or le
salaire de base et la durélie
d'assurance on leur importance dans le
calcul de la pension cette réforme
n'était pas allée au bout de la logique
ne s'appliquant pas aux femmes ayant eu
des enfants antérieurement au 1er
janvier 2012 l'amendement que je vous
présente permet d'ouvrir cette
possibilité pour celles qui partent en
retraite à compter du premier septembre
2023 si le montant d'indemnités
journalières versées n'est plus connu le
calcul pourra tenir compte d'un montant
forfaitaire en rapport avec le montant
des indemnités journalières dont peut
bénéficier un salarié rémunéré au niveau
du salaire médian l'année précédant le
congé maternité
depuis le début des débats dans notre
hémicycle nous sommes mobilisés sur le
droit des femmes et particulièrement des
maires se dispositif vise à soutenir les
femmes ayant connu des carrières très
hachées et ou ayant majoritairement
occupé des postes à mi-temps je vous
propose ici une mesure pour permettre de
rééquilibrer je vous remercie monsieur
le Président merci l'amendement 1906
monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues c'est un moment pour objectif
de corriger la situation des femmes dont
les maternités font baisser le niveau de
leur pension c'est particulièrement
sensible pour les femmes qui ont eu des
rémunérations autour du SMIC et qui
doivent alors pour bénéficier d'une
pension correcte travailler plus
longtemps
c'est pourquoi cet amendement propose
pour les retraites liquidés à partir du
1er septembre 2023 de prendre en compte
les congés maternité le présentement
permet d'ouvrir cette possibilité pour
celles qui partent en retraite à compter
du premier septembre 2023 si le montant
de l'indemnité journalière versé n'est
plus connu le calcul pourra donc tenir
compte d'un montant forfaitaire par
exemple par rapport
en rapport pardon avec le montant des
indemnités journalières dont peut
bénéficier un salarié rémunéré au niveau
du salaire médian l'année précédent le
congé maternité c'est une mesure de
justice à l'égard des femmes
particulièrement celles qui sont en bas
de l'échelle des salaires et qui vont
ainsi leur montant de leur pension
augmenter en fonction du nombre
d'enfants qu'elles ont eu les trimestres
de maternité étant ainsi neutralisés
cela viendra en par ailleurs compenser
les inégalités salariales entre les
femmes et les hommes subis tout au long
de la carrière et qui ont un effet
d'accentuer au moment de la liquidation
de la pension de retraite merci Monsieur
Cabanel oui merci monsieur le Président
maman demande identique très bien déf
endu par mes deux collègues
et Madame ponce et mange
merci monsieur le Président
prenant compte de l'inégalité que
peuvent subir les femmes qui ont eu des
enfants la loi du 9 novembre 2010 avait
proposé que les indemnités journalières
versées dans le cadre des congés
maternités commencent après le 1er
janvier 2012 soit désormais prise en
compte dans le salaire de base et non
uniquement il faut le souligner au titre
de la durée d'assurance requise servant
au calcul de la pension
cependant cette réforme n'était pas
allée au bout de sa logique de
s'appliquant pas aux femmes ayant eu des
enfants antérieurement au 1er janvier
2012 cela est malheureusement assez peu
compréhensible et constitue une nouvelle
fois une injustice envers les femmes qui
n'a que peu de fondements dès lors ce
qui est proposé via cet amendement c'est
de revenir sur ces dispositions et donc
de permettre que les indemnités
journalières des femmes avec enfants
soient prises en compte dans le salaire
de base savant calcul de la pension dans
le cas où le montant d'indemnités
journalières versées n'est plus connu il
est tenu compte alors d'un montant de
base qui est celui dont peut bénéficier
une salariée rémunérée au niveau du
salaire médian l'année précédant le
congé maternité cela semble une idée
raisonnable une dévoue de bon sens en
conséquence je salue la vie favorable de
la commission et espère l'adoption d'un
amendement qui ne peut qu'améliorer la
situation de nombreuses femmes dans le
pays merci alors l'avis de la commission
mais oui la vie du gouvernement
Nassim c'est le président pour rendre à
César ce qui est à César c'est le groupe
modem de l'assemblée qui avait appelé la
tension du Gouvernement sur ce sujet
avec Philippe Vigier et donc clavier la
vie est favorable avis favorable
un amendement qui porte le numéro
3343 et avec un autre amendement en
discussion commune madame monsieur
Fernique oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègue donc
c'est amendement que je présente
résolument quoi qu'un peu vainement
puisque la combinaison du 44.3 de la
constitution de 9 ne lui permet guère
d'amander la loi puisqu'il ne figure pas
contrairement à la maman précédente dans
la fameuse liste mais c'est encore plus
beau lorsque c'est inutile et puis le
ministre peut toujours se raviser comme
le voudrait le mouvement social donc cet
amendement est un amendement d'appel sur
de nombreux aspects de l'ASPA à fortiori
lorsqu'ils sont appliqués aux outre-mer
vous le savez la situation dans ces
territoires est particulièrement
dégradée selon l'INSEE en 2020 16 à 23%
d'individus vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté local dans les outre-mer aux
Antilles en Guyane une personne sur 5
vit en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
locale qui s'établit à 820 euros
nouvelle en Martinique et seulement 505
550 euros en Guyane en conséquence la
proportion de personnes ayant une
pension faible et qui dépend de l'assepa
est importante et malgré tout les sommes
versées au titre de la SPA sont
récupérés au décès de la locataire
au-delà d'un certain seuil ceci n'est
pas simplement injuste c'est dissuasif
et le non recours est évidemment
important dans le cas d'une
expérimentation menée par la CNAV visant
à contacter les personnes éligibles à un
spa les motifs de non recours invoqués
étaient la méconnaissance de la
prestation et l'existence de cette
fameuse récupération sur succession de
sorte que le taux de non recours est de
50%. je crois que nous priverons ici une
partie importante de la population d'une
aide non négligeable qui leur
permettrait de vivre un peu plus
dignement à leur retraite de manière
générale la reprise sur succession n'a
que peu de justification a fortiori
lorsqu'elle s'applique à une population
aussi défavorisée qu'en outre-mer nous
demandons donc à ce que cette
disposition soit supprimée afin que cela
lève un obstacle important à des
personnes dans le besoin je vous
remercie de votre attention
l'amendement suivant monsieur Gontard
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur le
monsieur le Président
malgré cette étudiant du 44-3 je vais
quand même présenter cette cette
amendement même si évidemment je sais
que je n'aurai pas de panores ni de vote
le taux de pauvreté pour les personnes
ayant 65 ans ou plus et de 4 quai 2
pardon 8,6% c'est évidemment
inadmissible il existe un certain nombre
d'outils pour lutter contre cette
probabilité des retraités comme
l'allocation solidarité aux personnes
âgées la SPA la SPA est une allocation
versée aux personnes de 65 ans ou plus
ou aux personnes inaptes sous un plafond
de ressources qui dépend de la situation
de la personne elle est versée par la
caisse de retraite à laquelle la
personne est affiliée
même s'il pourrait s'agir d'une
allocation qui permettrait effectivement
de lutter contre la provité des
personnes de 65 ans ou plus elle est on
le sait très mal connue en France un
rapport de l'adresse de mai 2022 et
catégorique après avoir établi que 646
800 personnes remplissent théoriquement
pour demander cette allocation seulement
325700 personnes sont effectivement
bénéficiaires de la SPA le taux de
Morocco est donc de cette allocation se
situe autour de 50%
en partie les potentiels bénéficiaires
ne sont tout simplement pas au courant
de l'existence de ce dispositif même si
celui-ci a été introduit il y a
désormais 17 ans cependant d'autres
hésites à demander l'ASPA car les sommes
versées à son titre sont récupérées au
décès d'allocataire sur sa succession si
l'axe n'est successoral est au moins
égal au seuil de recouvrement cette si
tu fais situation devrait nous
interroger sur deux choses est-ce que
les potentiels bénéficiaires sont-elles
suffisamment informées de leurs droits
est-ce que les conditions d'accès sont
appropriées ils conviendraient de
s'interroger notamment sur le fait qu'il
a récupération des versements qui a
décès sous certaines conditions de
rebutent pas certaines personnes
potentiellement éligibles la situation
est particulièrement inquiétant dans les
outre-mer notamment le taux de pauvreté
est 2 à 5 fois plus élevé qu'en France
métro uten pour ces raisons nous devons
donc le biais de cet amendement un
rapport au gouvernement évaluant pour
les outre-mer le taux de non recours à
la location de solidarité aux personnes
âgées les campagnes d'information et des
conditions d'attribution de cette
allocation merci David de la commission
monsieur favorable
alors nous allons passer à l'article 11
et
[Musique]
j'ai une première de terminer l'examen
de l'article 10 on va rejoindre Audrey
vuettaz on clôture donc l'examen de
cette article on l'a vu il y a pas de
vote à Audrey
les amendements sont défendus il y a des
avis un avis de la commission un avis du
gouvernement mais pas de votre même sur
les amendements qui ont été retenus par
le gouvernement je rappelle qu'il y en a
70 sur le millier qu'il restait à
examiner en fait il n'y aura qu'un vote
un vote final si la lieu avant demain
minuit sur l'ensemble du texte avec donc
les 70 amendements retenus par le
gouvernement entre l'article 9 au moment
où il a déclenché le 44-3 et l'article
20 le dernier article Audrey l'article
11 qu'est-ce qu'il y a dedans alors
l'enjeu sur cet article c'est de voir
pour prendre en compte certains
dans les trimestres cotisés on va voir
donc s'il y a des améliorations sur ce
sujet voilà et un dernier mot sur
l'article 10 on a vu qu'il y avait un
amendement de la commission sur la
majoration de 10% du montant des
pensions pour trois enfants pour les
professions libérales visiblement cet
amendement qui figure dans le vote
unique et bien et il a fait consensus
dans l'hémicycle retour direct
tombe 2023 j'évoque les travaux
d'utilité collective parce que je pense
que sur tous les bancs de cette
hémicycle nous avons reçu de très
nombreux messages venant des salariés
qui ont été des PUCistes et qui nous ont
sollicités sur la nécessité de remédier
à cette injustice mais hélas cette
avancée que je veux souligner comme
souvent vous n'allez pas au bout des
avancées alors que vous n'hésitez jamais
à aller au bout de vos idées
lorsqu'elles constituent une régression
sociale comme c'est le cas bien entendu
du passage à 64 ans de l'âge légal de
départ en retraite donc de qui
parlons-nous nous parlons de jeunes qui
étaient âgés dans les années 80 de 16 à
25 ans rémunéré à hauteur de 1250 francs
par mois et pris en charge par l'État en
fait ces cussiste et les autres étaient
des jeunes globalement plus précaires
que la moyenne et si vous n'assouplissez
pas les règles applica pour justifier
l'existence du contrat il est certain
que de trop nombreuses personnes
n'arriveront pas à faire valoir leur
droit je présenterai d'ailleurs un
amendement en ce sens pour améliorer ce
dispositif
Madame Corinne Ferret
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre cet article donc notamment la
traduction des travaux d'une mission
flash sur les tucques qui a été réalisé
par les députés Paul Christophe et
Arthur de Laporte il est donc on peut le
dire pertinent c'est en effet au début
des années 80 les tucs qui étaient
proposés par des administrations des
associations afin que des jeunes sans
emploi puisse insérer
professionnellement toutefois qu'on se
dispositif a été imaginé il n'a pas été
prévu que les trimestres passés dans ces
tuques comptent dans la retraite c'est
pourquoi les anciens bénéficiaires de ce
dispositif qui partent désormais à la
retraite se sont mobilisés récemment
pour obtenir un camp de cause et je veux
saluer cette mobilisation comme cela a
été dit beaucoup d'entre nous ont été
sollicités par par eux pardon en ce sens
nous avons aussi interpellé le ministre
sur ce sujet toutefois il est
regrettable de ne pas rendre rétroactive
la validation de trimestre pour les
personnes qui ont pris leur retraite
avant le premier septembre 2023 alors
que le gouvernement chiffre le coup de
cet article à moins de 100 millions
d'euros une fois la montée réaliser et
que seul 5% des assurés ayant réalisé
des tucs qui sont partis à la retraite
une telle être rétroactivité ne
coûterait pourtant qu'environ 5 millions
d'euros par an pour comparaison les
dépenses de retraite c'est léger à 345
milliards d'euros en 2021 et je me
conclure avec les quelques secondes qui
me reste pour dire que je regrette moi
aussi qu'il n'y ait plus de véritable
débats après les décisions que vous avez
prises d'activer les différents articles
bâillonnant ainsi le Sénat car ce nous
aurions pu évoquer les conséquences de
votre réforme pour les stagiaires de la
formation professionnelle qui sont les
futurs retraités et qui eux aussi
devront travailler deux ans de plus les
64 ans s'appliquent à tous c'est bien
deux ans de plus pour tous et toutes
malgré les trous dans la raquette si
vous le permettez qui ont pu être
révélés malgré les propositions de
d'accompagnement ou de prise en charge
que la première ministre vaut même
monsieur le ministre avait évoqué
on voit bien que beaucoup beaucoup vont
être impactés par cette réforme
totalement injuste brutale et
inacceptable merci
Madame lineman pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste
oui cet article
que nous aurions voté sans doute si nous
avions pu avoir un débat et un vote
vise à valider les trimestres cotisés
pendant les stages de formation
professionnelle on pense notamment au
tucs les travaux d'utilité collective
lancés dans les années
80 mais aussi les stages
d'insertion dans la vie publique mais il
n'avait pas été prévu à l'époque que les
trimestres passaient dans ces tu comptes
pour la retraite les anciens
bénéficiaires se sont mobilisés à juste
titre pour obtenir Yann cause cet
article répare en partie c'est injustice
en partie parce que une partie de
l'amélioration
indispensable ne pourra pas avoir lieu
au regard de votre article 49-3
sénatoriales qui va empêcher d'améliorer
les propositions gouvernementales sur un
point néanmoins extrêmement important en
particulier le gouvernement ne propose
pas de rendre étroite qu'il cette mesure
pour les personnes qui concernaient qui
prendraient leur retraite avant le 1er
septembre 2023 cet effet de seuil
particulièrement malvenu vous en
conviendrez au moins aussi important
cette validation des trimestres ne sera
pas automatique puisque il faudra que
chaque personne la demande à la caisse
de retraite
certes nul n'est sans ignorer la loi
mais nous savons bien que quand en
général c'est déjà difficile pour les
publics modestes mais quand en plus
cette loi est votée dans des conditions
unies comme celle-ci le risque est grand
que toutes les personnes concernées ne
soient pas un bien informé de cette
mesure chers collègues vous avez décidé
de dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
en appliquant de façon caustique tous
les arsenaux de la constitution et du
restaurant et nous ne laisserons pas
faire
bien alors maintenant nous allons
examiner huit amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune et
Madame vermillier le groupe de l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
notre système démocratique local repose
sur l'engagement des élus parfois au
détriment de leur activité
professionnelle et souvent de la
création de droit à retraite en effet
les élus qui perçoivent des indemnités
de fonction mensuelles inférieures à la
moitié du plafond de la sécurité sociale
1833 euros mensuels et qui n'ont pas
cessé toute activité professionnelle par
ailleurs ne cotise pas au régime de base
de la sécurité sociale il ne valide donc
pas nécessairement quatre trimestres par
an et leurs indemnités n'ouvrent aucun
droit à retraite au régime de base
plus de 80% des mers quasi exclusivement
de communes de moins de 4000 habitants
sont potentiellement concernés de
surcroît ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à réduire leur activité
professionnelle pour exercer leur mandat
pour leur permettre d'ouvrir des droits
retraite c'est amendement propose
d'offrir la possibilité à ses élus
locaux d'être assujetti au cotisations
de sécurité sociale donc la cotisation
d'assurance vieillesse sur l'indemnité
de fonction qu'il perçoivent cette
disposition s'exerce sur l'option de
l'élu donc de manière non obligatoire
tout assurer peut par ailleurs effectuer
un versement pour la retraite au titre
des années d'études supérieures et des
années de cotisation incomplètes ces
rachats de cotisations manquantes
permettent de conforter et de sécuriser
la pension de retraite des assurés ils
sont limités à 12 trimestres or l'actuel
dispositif de rachat de trimestre est
ouvert pour les années incomplètes
empêchant le rachat de trimestres pour
des années au cours desquelles un élu
n'en aurait validé aucun cet amendement
propose également d'ajouter les années
de mandat électoral à la liste des
situations permettant le rachat de
trimestres je remercie monsieur le
ministre madame et Messieurs les
rapporteurs d'avoir été sensible à cette
cause que je défends depuis des années
cette réforme va rendre justice à des
milliers de maires de petites communes
merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
l'amendement 2505 qui le défend madame
Ferré
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre tout d'abord vous dire vous
avez décidé de dévitaliser la fonction
parlementaire par les par l'addition de
toutes par l'addition de toutes les
procédures que vous offre que vous offre
la Constitution le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous les serions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées nous ne sommes pas
dupe les Français non plus et nous nous
lancerons rien et nous ne la lâcherons
pas sur cet amendement que nous
proposons avec plusieurs de mes
collègues c'est un amendement qui vise à
améliorer notre activité des mandats la
question se pose et réelle inférieure à
la moitié du plafond de la sécurité
sociale la possibilité d'être assujetti
à leur demande au cotisations de
sécurité sociale sur les indemnités de
fonction qu'ils perçoivent ils tend par
ailleurs à étendre le rachat de
trimestre de retraite aux périodes de
électorales indépendamment du nombre de
trimestres validés pour cette même année
en effet l'actuel dispositif de rachat
de trimestres est ouvert pour les années
incomplètes empêchant le rachat de
trimestre pour des années au cours
desquelles un élu n'en aurait validé
aucun vous le voyez on est sur une
proposition
identique à plusieurs de nos collègues
moi je me satisfait nous sommes nous
aurions nous aurions pu être dans un
débat serein dans l'intérêt l'intérêt
général de celles et ceux que nous
représentons qui sont les élus locaux la
chambre haute et la chambre des élus
voilà pourquoi nous proposons cet
amendement voilà pourquoi nous avons
décidé de d'accompagner on va dire et de
soutenir leur proposition leur
sollicitations parce que on le voit cet
engagement mais vous le savez Mesdames
et Messieurs mes chers collègues cet
engagement des hommes et des femmes qui
un jour se disent je pourrais être élu
je peux ainsi agir au nom de la courbe
générale et bien mérite cette
proposition
alors Monsieur le Ministre l'amendement
présenté par le gouvernement merci
Michel président il a été parfaitement
présenté par Madame vermeil et pour une
raison assez logique puisque nous avons
travaillé ensemble pour le préparer à
l'initiative de madame la sénatrice donc
la vie par définition favorable et si tu
me demandes de retrait pour les autres
amendements discussion commune merci
l'amendement 47 37 monsieur le
rapporteur oui vous rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales aussi
n'ont rien lâché madame Ferré en
conséquence nous sommes associés avec
Sylvie vermillier rapporteur pour avis
de la commission des finances pour faire
en sorte avec l'accord du gouvernement
de vous présenter cette mesure
essentielle pour nos élus
merci
madame la Présidente Nathalie Delattre
RDSE s'associe à ce travail vous savez
que nous préoccupons beaucoup du statut
de l'élu nous avons ici grâce à vous
tous puis progresser sur les agressions
d'élus là il s'agit effectivement d'une
autre reconnaissance celle du service
qu'ils mettent de leur service qu'ils
mettent au bien commun beaucoup d'entre
eux sont à la retraite pour pouvoir
assumer cette fonction des lieux locaux
il n'en reste pas moins que nombre de
travail et doivent mettre entre
parenthèses leur carrière
professionnelle voir l'abandonner et nos
cotise pas beaucoup de femmes notamment
qui doivent qui ainsi sacrifient
effectivement
leur retraite pour se mettre au service
du bien commun donc je pense que ce que
nous demandons aujourd'hui est une
mesure juste de reconnaissance et Sylvie
la techniquement très bien présenté je
rajouterai que tout cela se fait rachat
de trimestre sur
leur deniers propre il n'y a pas de
effectivement de cotisations sur les
biens donc voilà nous on nous associons
pleinement et à la demande de la
Commission pour
satisfaire nous retirons notre
amendement
alors le rendement 457 monsieur Julias
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues bien
évidemment nous voterons le très bon
amendement de Madame madame vermoyer ce
que ce que nous tenons à dire ici c'est
que il serait très utile que notre
Parlement est une discussion plus
générale non pas sur la seule retraite
des élus tous les élus mais sur le
statut de l'élu et je pense qu'il faut
qu'à un moment donné nous nous abordions
cette discussion et que nous
considérions que la retraite de l'élus
ce n'est juste un volet que d'une
question beaucoup plus générale que
celle de du statut d'élus non mais pour
cette raison nous nous voterons très
favorablement à cet amendement merci
monsieur le président
merci alors
un amendement 274 rectifiés
qui est identique madame Delattre oui
tout à fait c'est un manque replié mais
pour satisfaire encore la commission
nous le retirons
et un amendement 45006
rectifié bis madame à poursuppoli
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
vous avez décidé de dévitaliser la
fonction parlementaire par l'addition de
toutes les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous
que nous laissions la retraite des
Françaises et Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées nous ne sommes pas
dupes les Français non plus et vous le
diront cet après-midi dans la rue nous
ne lâcherons rien nous ne lâcherons pas
notre amendement comme
notre amendement comme les précédents
vivent évidemment à ouvrir la
possibilité
aux élus dont le montant total brut des
indemnités de fonction est inférieure à
1833 euros par mois ainsi qu'à ceux qui
n'ont pas cessé leur activité
professionnelle pour se consacrer à leur
mandat de cotiser au régime général
uniquement pour la vieillesse et ce avec
la participation de la collectivité la
couverture du risque vieillesse
constitue donc la question centrale de
la protection sociale des élus il nous
faut leur garantir comme ça a été dit un
droit à une retraite descente afin que
les élus locaux ayant consacré de
nombreuses années au service de leurs
concitoyens ne soient pas pénalisés au
moment de leur départ à la retraite et
puis évidemment mon collègue Pierre aux
oldias vient de le dire ce qu'il nous
faut c'est un véritable statue de l'élu
c'est en ce sens que notre amendement
donc vise à améliorer l'attractivité du
mandat et combattre la crise d'évocation
constatée en ce domaine particulièrement
dans les petites communes nous le savons
tous l'exercice d'un mandat local
constitue pour les élus une charge de
plus en plus lourde sous l'effet
conjugués de la poursuite des transferts
de compétences de l'État vers les
collectivités territoriales des
exigences de plus en plus importantes
merci merci alors
avons entendu déjà nous sommes en direct
sur Public Sénat et on le voit sur cet
article 11 il y a un débat sur les
retraites des mers un des élus locaux
cela concerne d'ailleurs un amendement
un ajout décentré se retenu par le
gouvernement dans le vote unique un
amendement Audrey qui fait qu'on s'en
suit son on peut le dire oui une fois
c'est un amendement qui est a été retenu
par le gouvernement pour le vote final
c'est un amendement de la centriste
Sylvie vermillier et c'est un peu on
peut le dire la pâte du Sénat qui
représente les territoires en effet cet
amendement consiste à permettre aux élus
de pouvoir cotiser sur leurs indemnités
s'il le souhaite est de pouvoir aussi
racheter certains de leurs trimestres
lorsqu'ils ont été en mandat alors après
que la sénatrice est défendue son
amendement on a entendu des
applaudissements qui venaient de tous
les rangs du Sénat vous le voyez donc un
amendement qui fait consensus puisqu'il
concerne les élus merci Audrey
cycle que vous offre la constitution et
le règlement vous espériez sans doute
ainsi que nous laissions la retraite des
Français entre les mains des droites
coalisées nous ne sommes pas dupe les
Français n'ont plus nous ne lâcherons
rien et nous ne les lâcherons pas
l'amendement 2214
[Applaudissements]
concerne les accepter concernent une
demande de faire accepter des
attestations sur l'honneur de
l'employeur pour justifier d'un TUC nous
avons parlé tout à l'heure de ces stages
et je dois dire que les salariés qui
sont informés en principe de la
nécessité de conserver leur document
administratifs bulletin de salaire
contrat de travail notamment pour
justifier de leurs droits à la retraite
mais dans la mesure où les Cuques
n'ouvraient aucun droit à la retraite et
de plus ils ont souvent été formalisés
par un simple formulaire CERFA on peut
imaginer que beaucoup de ces anciens
tucs n'ont pas les documents sous la
main pour faire valoir leurs droits à la
retraite suite à la possibilité de les
de les faire valoir qui pourraient être
voté sous la bienveillance du
gouvernementale dans le texte il est
donc à craindre que de nombreuses
personnes ayant Béné ficié d'un TUC ne
soit plus en possession d'un tel
document et on peut craindre aussi que
des emplois ailleurs ne les ai pas
conservés avec autant de soins que les
documents relatifs à l'ensemble des
salariés cet amendement vise donc à
permettre l'ouverture des droits au plus
grand nombre avec une simple attestation
sur l'honneur de l'employeur qui
servirait de justificatif
otusiste
alors l'amendement 4585
qui le présente
monsieur salmon
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues vous avez décidé de
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement vous espériez sans doute que
nous laissions la retraite des Français
entre les mains des droites coalisées
nous ne sommes pas dupes les Français
non plus nous ne lâcherons rien nous ne
les lâcherons pas on se rappelle les
tucs ces fameux travaux d'utilité
collective
contrat aidé créé en France en 1984 sous
le gouvernement de Laurent Fabius plus
d'un million de personnes ont occupé ces
contrats aidés alors qu'ils étaient
alors jeunes au chômage dans des
associations ou des collectivités des
contrats qui pouvaient aller jusqu'à 12
mois
l'état financier la rémunération des
tucs à hauteur de 1200 francs environ
180 euros soit un quart du SMIC de
l'époque pour 80 heures par mois mais il
ne cotisait pas assez pour permettre
l'acquisition de trimestre pour la
retraite beaucoup découvrez au moment du
départ que ces travaux d'utilité
collectives ne leur donnaient aucun
trimestre alors ce sont un million de
personnes voire 1,5 millions qui se
réjouissent que cette injustice soit
réparée
si elle est une avancée positive sa
prise en compte doit être facilité et
elle doit être rétroactive c'est
pourquoi pour moins d'injustice et
permettent une prise en compte effective
en facilitant l'établissement d'une
preuve nous proposons qu'une simple
attestation écrite de la structure au
sein de laquelle les travaux ont été
réalisés soit suffisantes pour
constituer un justicette justificatif
valable pour le calcul de la retraite je
vous remercie merci alors monsieur le
rapporteur les rapporteurs ne sont pas
plus dupe que Monsieur Salman il se sont
rendus compte que les propositions
faites étaient d'ordre réglementaires
donc avis défavorable
défavorable car réglementaire mais ma
vie
nous allons passer à l'amendement
suivant
l'amendement
4586 se fermait que les fonds
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
mini chers collègues c'est amendement
donc comme les précédents je le présente
résolument quoi qu'un événement puisque
je crois que vous avez décidé comment
dire de te dévitaliser la fonction
parlementaire par la combinaison de
toutes les procédures il faut le dire
que vous offre la constitution de
règlement vous espériez sans doute que
nous laisserions la retraite des
Français entre les mains des droites
coalisées mais nous ne sommes pas dupe
la journée du même nom est lointaine
dans l'histoire on ne la refera pas et
les Français non plus nous ne lâcherons
rien nous ne les lâcherons pas cet
amendement consiste à rajouter après le
mot décret les mots conseils d'état de
façon
à permettre qu'à minima le Conseil
d'État soit saisi du projet avec son
avis recueilli permettent une
consultation des organismes dans la vie
souhaitée merci de votre attention alors
la vie de la commission précisant
historiquement que la journée des dupes
s'est déroulée ici
[Musique]
au rapporteurs ne sont pas non plus
dévitalisés et ils ont donné un avis
défavorable sur ce type d'abonnement
répétitif toujours
identique d'une redoutable utilité qui
consiste à proposer que le décret soit
fixé par le Conseil d'État donc avis
défavorable merci alors ensuite nous
allons
la vie du gouvernement est identique
alors quatre amendements
et 7 sous amendements tout d'abord
madame Portel un amendement qui porte le
numéro 68 rectifiés merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues depuis le 1er janvier 2014
chaque trimestre d'apprentissage compte
comme un trimestre pour la retraite
c'est l'État qui se charge de payer des
cotisations manquantes si la
rémunération n'est pas suffisante en
revanche avant 2014 et plus précisément
du 1er juillet
1972 au 31 décembre 2013 la prise en
compte n'est que partielle et le nombre
de trimestres validés inférieurs au
nombre de trimestres d'apprentissage
réalisés pour combler cet écart il est
certes possible de racheter des
trimestres à un tarif réduit pour autant
dans un souci d'équité cette amendement
demande un rapport sur l'opportunité le
coût et la faisabilité de valider
rétroactivement pour le décompte de la
retraite les trimestres réalisés comme
apprenti avant la réforme de 2014 je
vous remercie
2916 la présidente Laurence Rossignol
vous avez donc ensemble décidé de
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
toutes les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement et votre
objectif est sans doute que nous les
vous laissions ensemble les droits de
coaliser décider de la retraite des
Français nous ne sommes pas dupe les
Français ne sont pas dues et à chacun de
nos amendements nous tenons à rappeler à
ceux qui nous regardent que nous ne
lâcherons rien et que nous les lâcherons
pas ceci étant
l'amendement 29 16 vise à améliorer à
permettre de donner les moyens
d'améliorer demain encore la réforme de
2014 la réforme de 2014 a permis la
validation des trimestres des apprentis
pour autant elle n'a pas eu de porter
rétroactives or il apparaît injuste
aujourd'hui mais c'est injustice et les
démultiplier par votre réforme votre
réforme des multiplie c'est toutes les
injustices du système de retraite c'est
ça le fond de l'affaire c'est qu'en
reportant de deux ans l'âge de la
retraite tout ce qui était injuste dans
le système devient exceptionnellement
injuste et ça nous cherchons nous encore
un peu alcorriger malgré ses procédures
c'est pour ça que nous proposons un
rapport certes je sais que le Sénat
n'aime pas les rapports en rapporteur
n'aime pas les rapports des rapports
parlementaires madame la Présidente non
plus personne n'aime les rapports sauf
nous puisque les rapports sont le seul
moyen que nous ayons d'attirer
l'attention
du gouvernement surtout ce qui
augmenterait les charges de l'État
puisque l'article 40 s'applique aussi à
la vie parlementaire donc nous demandons
un rapport afin d'étudier le coût et les
effets corrés la rétroactivité prévue
par la loi de 2014 de l'insertion des
trimestres faits par les apprentis dans
le décompte de leur trimestre de
retraite avec cet amendement nous
pensons donner à tout le monde tous les
outils pour que les apprentis qui ont
été apprentis avant 2014 et ils sont
nombreux puissent bénéficier de ces
trimestres
alors l'amendement 398 vous êtes
toujours avec moi en direct de
l'hémicycle on voit ses prises de parole
de chaque sénateur de gauche qui s'ouvre
par le même mot d'ordre lorsqu'il parle
oui vous l'avez peut-être remarqué les
groupes de gauche commencent chacune de
leurs interventions par les mêmes
éléments de langage ça commence en
disant vous dévitalisez la fonction
parlementaire en filigrane et critique
évidemment l'article 44-3 qui contraint
les débats ils disent ensuite vous êtes
les droites coalisées pourquoi parce que
la droite sénatoriale et le gouvernement
ont le même objectif faire voter le
texte avant la fin du temps
réglementaire demain à minuit il estime
donc que le gouvernement et la droite
sénatoriale ont le même objectif et puis
il termine en disant nous ne lâcherons
rien pourquoi parce qu'en ce moment en
ce moment aujourd'hui il y a une grande
journée de mobilisation qui est prévue
et c'est une manière de galvaniser les
manifestants effectivement Audrey ce
contexte de la septième mobilisation de
l'intersyndicale qui donc et bien a des
répercussions dans les débats ici au
Sénat retour au direct on continue à
écouter ce qui se joue
nous saluons la demande de Madame
assassy de ses collègues du groupe
communiste et les auteurs de ce sous
amendement souscrivent à l'idée des
auteurs de l'amendement d'une remise
d'un rapport visant à estimer le coût et
la faisabilité de
valider rétroactivement pour le décompte
de la retraite la trimestre réalisée
comme apprenti avant la réforme de 2014
néanmoins compte tenu de l'importance du
sujet et de l'urgence pour les anciens
apprentis concernés il apparaît
souhaitable que le rapport soit remis
avant un an après la promulgation de la
loi et que la date de remise soit fixée
à 6 mois après cette promulgation et
nous regrettons de ne pas pouvoir en
débattre vous avez décidé de dévitaliser
la fonction parlementaire par l'addition
de toutes les procédures que vous offre
la constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalis ées et bien non nous
ne sommes pas dupe les Français non plus
nous ne lâcherons rien nous ne les
lâcherons pas
l'amendement
4963 madame meunier oui merci monsieur
le prix comme leçon vos avis
défavorables concernant nos amendements
et nous amendements à mon tour de vous
dire que vous
dévalidaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addiction de toutes ces procédures
et ses rappels
que vous offre pardon la constitution et
le règlement vous espériez peut-être que
nous vous laissions ensemble à droite
les droites coalisées pour débattre des
retraites des Français mais cela n'est
pas le cas et nous sommes pas dupe les
Français non plus et nous ne lâcherons
rien cette sous-amendement
49 63 que je présente est pour
raccourcir les délais et faire en sorte
que ce soit vraiment un examen qui soit
fait le plus régulièrement possible et
que je date à 7 mois
merci un amendement
494 qui portait huit mois voilà merci
monsieur le Président nous vivons une
situation
inédite et on cherche les mots pour
qualifier à la fois la procédure et la
situation politique dans laquelle sont
on se trouve donc moi j'ai cherché sur
chaussettes qu'on pouvait dire de cette
situation et voilà ce qui m'a été
proposé vous avez décidé de dévitaliser
la fonction parlementaire par l'addition
de toutes les procédures que vous offre
la constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées nous ne sommes pas
dupe les Français non plus nous ne
lâcherons rien nous ne les lâcherons pas
alors je laisse l'intelligence
artificielle de côté et je défends cet
amendement au fond puisque un certain
nombre de catégories de français de
catégorie particulière se trouve très
impacté par les choix que vous avez fait
et nous souscrivons à la proposition de
de nos collègues communistes par Sousou
amende ments qui qui souhaitent la
remise d'un rapport qui est estimerait
le coût et la faisabilité de valider
rétroactivement pour le décompte de la
retraite les trimestres réalisés comme
apprentis avant la réforme de 2014
néanmoins contenu de l'importance du
sujet et de l'urgence pour les anciens
apprentis concernés il apparais
souhaitable que le rapport soit remis un
an avant la promulgation de la loi et
que la date de remise soit fixée huit
mois après cette 3 obligations
merci neuf mois
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues oui je sais que au sén
at nous pas beaucoup
mais nous n'avons plus beaucoup d'armes
pour lutter contre cette réformes
injuste parce que vous avez décidé de
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par la conjonction de toutes les
procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement alors vous
espériez sans doute que nous laisserions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droits de coalisées mais nous ne
sommes pas dupe les Français non plus
nous ne lâcherons rien et nous ne les
lâcherons pas alors cet amendement sous
amendement a pour objectif effectivement
de rendre le rapport permettant
d'estimer le coût et la faisabilité pour
valider rétroactivement pour le décompte
de la tête les trimestres réalisés comme
apprentis avant la réforme de 2014 et ce
dans les 9 mois je vous remercie merci
le Président chers collègues monsieur le
ministre une petite variante
ça vous convient
49,3 sénatoriales 44 3 de la
Constitution de la 5ème république
42 9 de notre règlement le gouvernement
a posé le joug sur le Sénat et on
connaît on sait ce que c'est chez moi le
joug et notre débat est désormais
entravé par la collusion droite et
l'ISEN droite sénatoriale c'est un fait
politique majeur dont les 70% de
français opposés à votre réforme ont
pris acte pour aujourd'hui ils le diront
une septième fois cet après-midi dans
les rues
et pour demain et pour demain à
l'occasion d'autres motifs ou d'autres
objets de vote de plus grande portée
pour l'avenir de notre pays alors avec
mon groupe nous souscrivons à l'idée
d'une remise d'un rapport effectivement
il nous reste à peu près que ça
aujourd'hui pour travailler correctement
au service des Français rapport visant à
estimer le coût et la faisabilité de
valider rétroactivement pour le décompte
de la retraite et bien entendu les
trimestres réalisés comme apprentis
avant la réforme de 2014 est néanmoins
compte tenu l'importance du sujet et de
l'urgence pour les anciens apprentis
concernés il apparait souhaitable que le
rapport soit remis avant un an après la
promulgation de la loi et que la date de
remise soit fixée à 10 mois après cette
promulgation et je profite de de la
lecture de la présentation de cet
amendement pour dire combien
l'apprentissage reste quelque chose de
absolument fond amental dans notre pays
et que dans nos débats futurs j'espère
que nous allons nous aurons l'occasion
de renforcer parce que c'est nécessaire
l'apprentissage en France des premiers
des premiers niveaux professionnels
jusqu'au plus haut niveau ingénieur et à
cet égard je trouve que l'Allemagne est
un modèle plutôt à suivre qui a démontré
sa performance sur ce sujet même si on a
progressé on a encore beaucoup de retard
merci merci
qui présente l'amendement suivante qui
porte
du Rhin bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur socialiste de Saône-et-Loire on
vient de vous entendre prendre la parole
vous et de nombreux collègues de gauche
tous avec le même paragraphe que vous
lisez en introduction de la défense de
votre amendement sur ces mêmes mots la
dévitalisation du Parlement par
l'utilisation de toutes les règles du
règlement et de la Constitution elle
contre la droite coalisée et vous dites
que nous ne lâcherons rien c'est quoi ce
petit happening écoutez c'est une façon
de rythmer le débat et de revenir à
l'essentiel de nos convictions
il y a des sujets dans la période une
procédure parlementaire dévoyée depuis
le début et ce qui se passe au Sénat
n'échappe pas à au péché originel de cet
article
47-1 et puis l'autre aspect c'est un
aspect politique social qui concerne les
Français c'est que
l'absence de concertation syndicale le
mépris pour la dém
[Musique]
partager la réforme de Monsieur Macron
ils vont aussi partager la popularité et
quand vous dites nous ne lâcherons rien
et qui la dernière phrase que vous
utilisez dans ce petit paragraphe que
vous prononcez maintenant depuis une
heure à chaque fois que vous prenez la
parole c'est de dire aussi d'envoyer un
message aux personnes qui manifestent
c'est bien ça oui plusieurs choses ça
dit d'abord que les trois groupes de
gauche ici font un travail remarquable
et que
90 sénateurs et effectivement vous
lâchez rien on voulait vous défendez
tous vos amendements en tout cas le bloc
de gauche
ici au Sénat défend ses amendements
pieds à pied ça dit aussi que c'est un
combat acharné mais respectueux pas de
noms d'oiseaux pas de débordement pas
d'esclandre l'utilisation tous les
moyens parlementaires mis à notre
disposition mais dans le respect à la
fois des institutions et de la
correction qu'on doit au départ
parlementaire et puis ça dit évidemment
qu'on est en soutient du mouvement
social de la manifestation des
manifestations du jour et des Français
qui s'exprime par des mails par des
commentaires Facebook sur nos sur nos
comptes et qui nous disent je suis cassé
je n'en peux plus continuer ça c'est la
version optimiste et puis la version un
petit peu moins optimiste c'est ce qui
nous disent je suis pas de votre partie
je vote pour la droite c'est formidable
ce que vous faites mais la prochaine
fois je voudrais pour la nationale il y
a une très lourde responsabilité de ceux
qui veulent faire passer en force cette
réforme aujourd'hui un mot sur le
calendrier parlementaire puisque le
Sénat dispose encore de quelques heures
jusqu'à demain minuit pour examiner le
texte il y a encore plusieurs centaines
d'amendements qu'est-ce qui va se jouer
dans les prochaines heures est-ce que
vous pensez que il peut y avoir un vote
aujourd'hui par exemple ça me paraît
aujourd'hui ça me paraît difficile parce
qu'il y a quand même beaucoup
d'amendements alors peut-être y a-t-il
encore quelques manœuvres procédure qui
permettraient de faire tomber
plusieurs centaines d'amendements on est
je crois 600 et quelques amendements qui
restent en débat donc il faudra les
examiner quand même on ira sans doute
demain dans la journée et peut-être
heureusement
espérons-le plus tard notre but est
évidemment de d'empêcher le vote on
l'assume parfaitement parce qu'on pense
que c'est le meilleur moyen d'être en
cohérence avec ce que les Français
attendent j'ai une dernière question
c'est justement la droite et le centre
font parviennent à voter la réforme des
retraites demain est-ce que vous
craignez que ça affaiblisse la
mobilisation non je crois pas parce que
je pense et ça me semble être
l'essentiel de ce qu'on a à se dire ce
matin je pense que la colère qui est
enquistée dans le pays est très très
profonde et qu'il faut l'entendre et
qu'il y a grand péril à persévérer dans
cette stratégie du passage en force
on a eu le quoiqu'il en coûte
aujourd'hui c'est quoi qu'ils en disent
donc je pense que c'est pas très
important de continuer comme ça merci
Jérôme Durin pour cette réaction merci
d'avoir été le premier invité de cette
grande édition spéciale le direct qui se
poursuit c'est Guillaume Gontard le chef
de fil des écologistes à la parole dans
les muscles on l'écoute trop activement
les trimestres des apprentis réalisés
avant l'entrée en vigueur de la réforme
de 2014 et j'en profite pour envoyer une
petite salutation à Justin un apprenti
que je connais bien merci merci
alors la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur sur ces amendements et
sous amendements
merci vos rapporteurs en tout cas n'ont
pas eu besoin de chatity pour répondre à
ses amendements répétitifs qui tire vers
l'obstruction d'ailleurs poser la
question à chaque gipiti s'il a
répétition permet de faire avancer le
débat et nous donnons effectivement un
avenir un avis et nous donnant un avis
défavorable au rapport c'est parce que
nous avons vu faire comme Madame
Rossignol était ministre elle donnait un
avis négatif à l'ensemble des rapports
parce qu'il n'était pas suffisamment
déposés ras plus rappelez-vous madame
Rossignol rappelez-vous c'est la raison
pour laquelle effectivement nous donnera
un avis de négatif pierre ouzulia merci
d'avoir soulevé un problème important en
ce qui concerne cette apprentissage
parce que c'est ça qui est important
c'est pas la répétition d'amendement
identique c'est l'apprentissage et vous
avez
je voulais vous rappeler que à l'article
7 on a pris un amendement qui permet la
prise en compte des trimestres
d'apprentissage racheté pour le bénéfice
de la retraite anticipée pour carrière
longue c'est quand même une avancée
merci
monsieur le ministre
merci Monsieur Président c'est un avis
défavorable sur ces demandes de rapport
mais la loi 2014 a effectivement permis
aux apprentis d'avant 2014 de racheter
des trimestres lorsque ces trimestre
n'avaient pas été suffisamment cotisé
c'était un progrès qui nécessitait de
racheter ces trimestres 2014 n'avait pas
prévu d'intégration rétroactive pour des
questions de coûts budgétaire je souris
en entendant parler de la loi 2014 pour
cet aspect là puisque cette loi 2014 qui
traditionnellement appelée loi Touraine
a justement fait l'adoption avec un vote
unique à l'occasion de l'examen ce qui
est démonstration que les réforme de
retraite avec un vote unique ne sont pas
une spécialité ou une particularité de
ce gouvernement et de cette majorité
présidentielle et enfin sur la porter
l'a dit à l'article 7 un amendement a
été adopté qui permet à la fois
d'intégrer les trimestres rachetés dans
les trimestres prises en compte pour le
départ de civil au-dessus des carrière
longue puisque le rachat trimestre prévu
par la loi 2014 n'autorisait pas leur
intégration dans les conditions
d'éligibilité au dispositif de carrière
longue et donc au départ anticipé et
nous avons pris l'engagement de
faciliter l'information et les
conditions de rachat de cette trimestre
d'apprentissage avec un montant de
rachat forfaitaire alors que pour tous
les attrachats c'est une méthode
actuelle donc plus coûteuse
si nous avons passé à l'examen de deux
amendements et trois sous amendements
tout d'abord l'amendement 4588 monsieur
ferdinck le présente oui merci monsieur
le Président
je voudrais profiter de l'occasion de
cet amendement pour pour dire au
gouvernement comme à la majorité c'est
notre royale vous avez fait un choix
celui de vider de sa vitalité le
Parlement par la combinaison de tous les
procédés que vous fournissent la
Constitution réglement vous escomptiez
sans doute que nous abandonnions la
retraite des Français aux soins des
droites liguées mais nous ne sommes pas
les dindons de la farce les Français non
plus nous ne flancherons en rien nous ne
les laisserons pas tomber
pour les tucs l'étude d'impact anticipe
quand même un taux de recours à la
validation des trimestres de seulement
10%. c'est extrêmement faible alors si
l'étude d'impact anticipe un recours si
faible et insatisfaisant il semble
indispensable d'entamer un travail pour
améliorer cette mesure et faire en sorte
qu'elle bénéficie au plus grand nombre
la remise d'un rapport sur le taux de
non recours dispositif paraît donc
nécessaire c'est ce que vous propose cet
amendement merci un abonnement de
présenté par
Madame linman
et oui chers collègues vous avez décidé
de dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la Constitution le
règlement et Monsieur le Ministre bien
sûr vous avez noté la réforme Touraine
avait été voté par un vote bloqué ce qui
est d'ailleurs jamais bon signe jamais
bon signe mais les faits cumulatif à la
fois de l'inscription pfss à la fois
dans la capacité du de l'Assemblée de
voter à la fois du vote bloqué et de
toutes les procédures réglementaires de
Baillon permettez-moi de vous dire c'est
quand même
hyperarissime vous espériez sans doute
que nous laissions la retraite entre vos
mains les droites coalisées mais nous ne
sommes pas dupe les Français non plus
ils ne lâcheront rien et nous ne les
lâcherons pas nous ne les lâcherons pas
non plus
sur l'immense question du non recours au
droit dans ce pays c'est pourquoi nous
nous déposons un amendement qui demande
un rapport dans les trois ans sur l'état
réel du recours au droit dans ce cas
particulier car il s'agit en général
dans leur pour le non-couronne droit de
personnes souvent très modestes souvent
qui ont de milieu défavorisés et qui
sont particulièrement perdants par ce
non recours alors ne nous dites pas
qu'il faut pas de rapport parce que
cette question elle revient de façon
récurrente alors on peut avoir des
grands rapports sur le non recouvre
droit en général mais parti il faut
étudier cas par cas car le fait que vous
n'ayez pas recours au droit pour les
allocations logement n'est pas du tout
comparable au fait que vous n'ayez pas
recours sur votre trimestre et en tout
cas il faut veiller à ce que
l'information donnait notamment par les
collectivités les associations
qui en bénéficié des tufs au contraire
l'égalité des droits
merci sous amendement monsieur le
questeur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je n'ai
vraiment pas l'habitude de lire des
papiers ici je préfère m'adresser à mes
collègues en les regardant et sans être
embarrassé de documents mais je tiens à
faire aujourd'hui une exception car j'ai
l'honneur en solidarité avec tous mes
amis
des groupes de gauche de vous dire que
vous avez décidé de
dévitaliser d'anesthésier la fonction
parlementaire monsieur le Président par
l'addition de toutes les procédures que
vous offre la constitution et le
règlement vous espériez sans doute que
nous laissions la retraite des Français
entre les mains des droites coalisées
nous ne sommes pas dupe les Français non
plus nous ne lâcherons rien nous ne les
lâcherons pas et alors pour en venir à
l'objet de l'amendement
madame linman l'a très bien défendu
cependant je connais madame linmann
depuis quelques temps et je sais combien
elle est vive active et elle a un souci
constant d'efficacité et j'ai trouvé là
que c'était peut-être un peu long ma
chère collègue datant de 3 ans pour ce
rapport alors pour respecter je suis sur
votre état d'esprit votre état d'esprit
votre volonté d'agir votre efficacité
votre tempérament et bien nous allons
proposer que ce rapport soit remis au
bout d'un an ça nous paraît quand même
raisonnable trois ans c'est peut-être
plus sénatorial mais dans l'optique
traditionnel où l'on emploie ce mot
alors que nous avons monsieur le
Président une conception résolument
moderne du Sénat de la République
bien
un amendement 4969 qui va nous proposer
un autre délai madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le président
Jean collègue qui doit être pris très au
sérieux c'est notre collègue Jean-Pierre
soeur et sa démonstration devrait vous
inciter et à apporter plus d'attention à
nos amendements
d'autant que d'autant que pourquoi ce
débat mais tout simplement parce que
vous avez décidé de dévitaliser la
fonction parlementaire ceci par
l'addition de toutes les procédures que
vous offre la constitution et le
règlement du Sénat vous espériez sans
doute que on allait vous laisser
tranquillement entre vous décidez de la
retraite des Français et bien nous ne
sommes pas duple les Français non plus
nous ne lâcherons rien ni sur aucun ni
sous amendements ou nos amendements nous
ne lâcherons pas les Français non plus
j'entends pour autant régulièrement
évoqué l'idée que ce le rappel que ce ne
serait pas la première fois que
l'article 44-3 serait appliqué au Sénat
j'attire quand même votre attention
qu'il y a qu'il y a cette fois-ci une
quelque chose d'inédit en général
l'article 44-3 est utilisé quand un
gouvernement craint qu'une assemblée le
Sénat en l'espèce qui n'est pas d'accord
avec lui vote des amendements dont la
dans le gouvernement ne voudrait pas
or en l'espèce vous êtes totalement
d'accord avec la réforme du gouvernement
j'y viens j'y viens chers collègues vous
êtes d'accord et je me suis demandé mais
quel est en fin de compte l'amendement
visé par l'article 44.3 de quel
amendement le gouvernement ne veut pas
c'est probablement celui de Monsieur
retaillon nous verrons tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs si dès maintenu pas maintenu
ce que le gouvernement fera et en fin de
compte ça vous arrange bien qu'on soit
là parce que ça vous permet de faire
croire aux Français que c'est nous la
gauche qui vous avons poussé au 44,3
alors que ceci n'est qu'une affaire
entre le gouvernement et la droite la
plus dure à l'encontre des salariés
celles qui vont mettre fin aujourd'hui
au régime spéciaux
alors
[Applaudissements]
monsieur Ferron 4968
merci monsieur le Président comme
on disait à l'école chers collègues vous
recopierez 100 fois
vous avez décidé de dévitaliser la
fonction parlementaire par l'addition de
toutes les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées mais nous ne
sommes pas dupe et les Français n'ont
plus ils le montreront encore tout à
l'heure pour notre part nous ne
lâcherons rien et nous ne les lâcherons
pas car non nous ne lâcherons pas les
Français face à la brutalité qui leur
est faite aujourd'hui nous ne les
lâcherons pas face à l'injustice de
cette réforme nous ne les lâcherons pas
face à la crise politique et sociale qui
se profile dans notre pays et nous ne
les lâcherons pas face aux risques
populistes très lourd très grave
qu'entraîne le passage en force de cette
réforme et donc
sous amendements vise à renforcer
l'amendement présenté par notre collègue
nos collègues ferriques et assassis pour
limiter le non recours au droit et ce
sous amendement vise à ce que le rapport
qui sera produit soit présenté devant
les commissions compétentes de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat je
vous remercie merci
ensuite un amendement
alors l'avis de la commission
vide la commission excusez-moi monsieur
le Président oui effectivement c'est
déjà fini donc très bien
le non recours est un vrai problème
parce qu'il faut en revenir sur le sujet
quand même au-delà des postures
politiciennes que vous affichez nous
nous sommes sensibles à ce problème de
non recours c'est la raison pour
laquelle je me tourne vers monsieur le
ministre parce que dans vos estimations
par rapport à la prise en compte
effectivement ces dispositifs de reprise
de stage il semblerait que le taux de
recours soit relativement faible de 10%,
est-ce que vous pensez réellement qu'il
n'y ait pas une campagne qui ne serait
pas nécessaire faire une campagne de
communication pour faire en sorte de
l'améliorer merci en tout cas à vie
défavorable par rapport à l'amendement
et par rapport aux sous-amendements
c'est un avis très personnel je n'ai pas
eu l'occasion de les étudier puisque ils
ont été déposés au dernier moment dans
un but d'obstruction du débat
parlementaire en conséquence la
commission n'a pas pu se réunir
la vue du gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président la vie est
défavorable de mots d'abord pour dire à
Monsieur rapporteur que la campagne de
communication vous évoquez est prévue et
que j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure que nous
voulions renforcer les modalités
d'information sur les possibilités de
rachat de stage rachat de stage d'études
rachète très belle apprentissages tout
ce qui permet de faire valoir les droits
et d'augmenter le taux de recours la
deuxième chose c'est que des caractères
répétitifs de certains arguments peut
confiner l'obstruction leur apportera
dit mais permet aussi de souligner que
les dispositions prises par votre
conférence des présidents monsieur le
Président demandez par certains prisons
de groupes aux mises en oeuvre par le
gouvernement relève toutes de la
Constitution et du Règlement ce qui
témoigne aussi de leur régularité
merci nous allons examiner maintenant
deux amendements
identiques sous amendements l'amendement
de 1914 madame Pomerol
oui merci monsieur le Président je
comprends bien sur le rapporteur Richard
collègue que la répétition vous agace
si si je le sens bien mais sachez que
depuis 10 jours elle l'a simplement
amendement après un manquement il nous
en présenter je ne sais plus si c'est
5000 ou 6000 même si vous en avez
supprimé d'un coup notre Soi par un
artifice plus de 1000 elle l'a
simplement vous n'aurez vous nous
répétez un avis négatif et défavorable
donc pensez que
nous puissions utiliser nous aussi vous
vos méthodes et que bien que vous ayez
décidé de dévitaliser la fonction
parlementaire par l'addition de toutes
les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous vous
espériez sans doute par là que nous
laisserions à la retraite des Français
entre les la main les mains des droites
coalisées bien non nous ne sommes pas
dupe et les Français non plus nous ne
lâcherons pas nous nous face à cette
réforme brutale et injuste l'amendement
que je des fois au nom de mon groupe
concerne les
demandes encore une fois d'une rapport
d'un rapport puisque nous n'avons pas
d'autres arts pour un aménagement du
dispositif de retraite des sportifs de
haut niveau c'est la demande donc est
une demande de rapport pour l'améliorer
puisqu'il a été institué en 2012 et il
concerne à hauteur de haute de 4
trimestres la possibilité de rachat nous
demanderons que cela puisse être
rallongé parce que ça a duré moyenne
d'inscription sur la liste de haut
niveau pour les sportifs comme
l'athlétisme ou l'aviron se situe entre
8 et 10 ans l'ouverture des droits sur
quatre ans ne recouvrant ainsi même pas
la moitié d'une carrière internationale
et la précocité de certaines gardiens
sportives fait aussi que ce dispositifs
qui ne commence qu'à 20 ans pelipe est
un disait donc certains peuvent être
amenés à travailler jusqu'à 70 ans nous
condamandons donc une évolution de
conclure et donc le rapport concernant
cet allongement
alors pour le groupe comme Julia
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues je
vais retirer cet amendement parce que il
est satisfait par l'amendement de
Monsieur Savin qui a été qui a été volé
voté pardon même si j'ai regretté non
non non pas voler ici il y a jamais de
vol on s'est mis même si même si j'ai
regretté que on puisse pas utiliser la
même procédure pour les chercheurs de
haut niveau qui qui auraient pu aussi
voir leur retraite qu'ont mais avant
j'aimerais vous dire un petit mot
ça ou tu aimes nomme dignité
et hausse merci monsieur le Président
l'amendement 4971 voilà on va ses prises
de paroles un des sénateurs de gauche
qui continuent et qui soit introduite
soit et bien il place un peu plus loin
dans leur prise de parole mais ils ont
les mêmes éléments de langage et il est
répète à l'envie dans l'hémicycle Audrey
c'est ça ce que l'on voit c'est cette
stratégie de la gauche oui et ça donne
parfois lieu un comique de répétition
car chaque sénateur prend le même texte
en le mettant dans ses mots ça donne
lieu à des applaudissements dans les
rangs de la gauche un peu d'agacement
dans les rangs de la droite ces éléments
de langage quels sont-ils d'abord ils
commencent en disant vous délit
dévitalisez la fonction parlementaire il
critique en filigrane tous les articles
qui ont été utilisés pour contraindre
les débats avec à la fin l'article 44 3
qui contraint donc les débats ensuite
ils annoncent vous êtes les droites
coalisées en fait critique en filigrane
le fait que la droite sénatoriale les
centristes et le gouvernement ont le
même objectif finalement faire voter ce
texte avant demain soir minuit et enfin
il termine en disant nous ne lâcherons
rien car vous le savez aujourd'hui il y
a une grande journée de mobilisation qui
est prévue c'est une manière de
galvaniser les manifestants Quentin oui
Audrey sur le fond on est dans l'article
11 on parle de ces tuques ces travaux
d'utilité collectives c'est bien ça oui
c'est l'un des points de cet article
c'est de prendre en compte ces travaux
d'utilité collective dans le calcul des
pensions alors les tucs qu'est-ce que
c'est c'était des emplois aidés qui ont
mis qui ont été mis en place dans les
années 80 dans des secteurs d'utilité
publique c'était une manière de lutter
contre le chômage et de faciliter
l'insertion professionnelle jusqu'à
présent et sais-tu que n'était pas pris
en compte dans le calcul des pensions le
projet de loi devrait rectifier cela
mais pas pour les personnes qui partent
à la retraite cette année c'est ce qui a
souligné la gauche lorsqu'elle a défendu
ses amendements des amendements avec
lesquels elle aurait voulu régler cette
situation mais vous le savez ces
amendements n'ont pas été retenus dans
le vote final n'ont pas été sélectionnés
par le gouvernement et merci Audrey pour
toutes ces explications je rajouterai
juste que entre 1984 et 1990 la concerné
plus d'un million de jeunes qui ont
signé ce type de contrats retours au
direct dans l'émission
par Monsieur le Ministre qui a jugé
utile de nous rappeler que les
procédures utilisées étaient légales
mais c'est bien le moi monsieur le
ministre et j'espère bien que si c'était
pas le cas l'indignation ne viendrait
pas que sur les bancs de la gauche elle
serait partagée par la totalité du Sénat
vous avez nous avons sur votre choix
d'utiliser ces procédures un jugement
politique nous considérons que ces
procédures dévitalisent le Parlement je
dirais pas plus loin et c'est un
jugement politique mais nous avons nous
aussi recours à des procédures
parfaitement légales le droit
d'amendement des parlementaires vous
émettez un jugement politique sur les
procédures auxquelles nous recourons le
droit d'amendement en pensant que sont
des procédures d'obstruction alors
monsieur le ministre nous pouvons
échanger des jugements politiques mais
je m'inquiète quand même du fait que
vous jugez utile de rappeler que vos
procédures sont légales ça veut dire que
vous pourriez peut-être en pensez à des
procédures qui seraient moins conformes
madame Cohen oui même
44 bis moi je réagis par rapport aux
propos de notre rapporteur disons qu'il
n'a pas pu examiner nos sous amendements
parce qu'ils sont arrivés
au mauvais moment etc ou au dernier
moment alors moi je vais vous dire quand
même quelque chose que je dénonce avec
mon groupe c'est que le 44.2 n'a été
rendu possible qu'avec la complicité de
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales qui n'a pas voulu
réunir la commission des affaires
sociales c'est un fait car le 44-2 mes
chers collègues si vous ne le saviez pas
on commence à devenir expérimenter ne
s'applique que si les amendements ou les
sous amendements n'ont pas été examinés
par la commission moralité si la
commission des affaires sociales avait
été réunis il n'aurait pas pu y avoir ce
44 2 voilà mes chers collègues ce que je
dénonce avec l'ensemble dans mon groupe
merci nous allons poursuivre par trois
amendements et deux sous amendements en
discussion commune
l'abonnement de 1915 à la meunier oui
monsieur le Président avant de vous
présenter cette amendement je dois vous
redire que vous avez décidé de
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement vous espériez sans doute que
nous laissions la retraite des Français
entre vos mains droite ensemble on
réunis mais nous ne sommes pas dupe et
les Français non plus nous ne lâcherons
rien et nous ne lâcherons pas cet
amendement monsieur le président
vise à remettre un rapport au Parlement
et oui vous allez me dire un rapport
mais qu'est-ce qui nous reste finalement
les rapports pour évaluer et donc
évaluer la possibilité de rendre
rétroactif la validation comme trimestre
cotisé de période travaillées en stage
professionnel c'est important les stages
professionnels dans le cadre par exemple
utilité collective que sont les tuques
on en a parlé sur
l'article précédent mais dans bon nombre
de domaines alors que l'article 8 le
prévoit lui qu'une telle validation pour
les personnes qui partent à la retraite
ne serait possible qu'à partir du 1er
septembre 202
alors ensuite un amendement et 86
rectifié qui a deux sous amendements sur
les lecques
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
maïs
mais bien chers collègues
à mon tour je vous le dis
vous avez décidé de dévitaliser la
fonction parlementaire
par l'addition des procédures que vous
offre la constitution et le règlement
vous espériez sans doute que nous
laissions la retraite des Français entre
les mains des droites coalisées nous ne
sommes pas dupes les Français n'ont plus
nous ne lâcherons rien nous ne lâcherons
pas et c'est le sens de l'amendement
présent qui vise
à améliorer le statut des stagiaires des
stagiaires en formation professionnelle
continue
donc tout simplement avec le système des
trimestres validés par an d'une année
sur l'autre et bien ces années peuvent
donner lieu à des validations tout à
fait aléatoires
en conséquence il apparaît que les
trimestres chômés à l'instruire des
trimestre travaillé sont de factômes
mieux pris en compte que le choix de
faire une formation professionnelle qui
est quand même un engagement personnel
certes des améliorations ont été
adoptées je pense notamment à la loi de
2014 de même que votre projet de loi qui
apporte des améliorations que nous
aurions du reste pu voter
il reste que la rétroactivité n'est pas
résolue et enfin se pose quand même un
problème de communication et
d'information pour les éventuels
bénéficiaires et disons cela j'ai aussi
une pensée particulière
pour les tucs et autres catégories merci
de votre attention merci
sous amendement 4937 à
merci monsieur le Président alors comme
de nombreux collègues ici en avril 2021
j'avais alerté le ministre du travail
sur la prise en compte des travaux
d'utilité collectives dans le calcul des
droits à la retraite entre 85 et 1985 et
90 l'état employé plus de 350 000
personnes sous contratus
âgées de 18 à 20 ans les chômeurs de
l'époque ont accepté des missions de
service public afin de ne pas être radié
par la NPE de l'époque cette personne
approchent actuellement là je la
retraite la réponse qui m'avait été
faite par le ministre lors de mon
interpellation rien n'était spécifié
dans leur contrat de travail ils
n'étaient pas considéré comme des agents
mais comme des stagiaires de la
formation professionnelle et de ce fait
cette période n'est pas comptabilisée
pour la retraite grâce à leur
mobilisation sans faille et au travail
d'un certain nombre de parlementaires
ils ont obtenu gain de cause c'est une
avancée positive ils n'ont rien lâché et
nous non plus vous avez décidé de
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement vous espériez sans doute que
nous laissions les retraites des
Français entre les mains des droites
coalisées nous ne sommes pas dupes les
Français n'ont plus nous ne lâcherons
rien comme ces personnes qui ont
effectué des tubes des tubes nous ne les
lâcherons pas
nous regrettons cependant que la
validation des trimestre ne puisse pas
être faite de manière rétroactive pour
ces personnes ayant bénéficié d'un
contratus qui ayant déjà pris leur
retraite avant le 1er septembre 2023
c'est une double peine pour eux nous
regrettons que la validation des
trimestres soient pas automatiquement
faite par les caisses de retraite il y
aura probablement de nombreuses
personnes qui n'y auront pas recours on
sait que le tonnes ont recours au droit
est déjà de 30% dans ce pays donc nous
soutenons cet amendement du groupe
communiste et nous pensons importants
qu'un rapport soit fait pour sur la
possibilité de rendre rétroactive la
validation comme pour conclure
cotiser pardon ces périodes de tuques
merci 4972
[Musique]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre mon appel
à lire ensemble tout à l'heure la phrase
rituelle n'ayant pas été entendu je vais
la répéter parce que je suis pas sûr que
tout le monde est maîtrisé la totalité
de des mots
vous avez décidé de dévitaliser la
fonction parlementaire par l'addition de
toutes les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite défense des Français entre
les mains des droites coalisées nous ne
sommes pas dupe les Français non plus
nous ne lâcherons rien voilà donc je
pense qu'à force ça peut permettre
d'avoir une lecture commune
la main demain souscrit à la remise d'un
rapport sur la possibilité de rendre
rétroactive à la validation comme
trimestre cotisée des périodes
travaillées un stage de formation
professionnelle dont celle effectuée
dans le cas des travaux d'utilité
collective Les tucs et afin que ce
rapport ne reste pas l'être morte il
souhaite que soit expressément prévu au
terme de la loi que celui-ci face
l'objet d'un débat dans les deux
commissions parlementaires des affaires
sociales je vous remercie merci monsieur
ferdic
si monsieur le Président Monsieur le
mini chers collègues le gouvernement ne
propose pas de rendre rétroactive la
validation de trimestre pour les tucs
ayant déjà pris leur retraite avant le
1er septembre 2023 c'est un peu la
double peine pour eux c'est amendement
donc pour objet de demander à la CNAV un
rapport sur la possibilité de rendre
rétroactif la validation comme trimestre
cotisée les périodes travaillées en
stage de formation professionnelle dont
celle dans le cadre des tucs alors que
le texte ne prévoit une telle validation
que pour les personnes partant à la
retraite à partir du 1er septembre 2023
je crois qu'il me reste un peu de temps
je voudrais donc marteler une fois de
plus pour que nul ne l'ignore que vous
avez décidé de dévitaliser la fonction
parlementaire par l'addition de tous les
procédés que vous offre la constitution
et le règlement vous espériez sans doute
que nous laisserions la retraite des
Français entre les mains des des droites
coalisées et bien nous ne sommes pas
dupe les Français non plus nous ne
lâcherons rien nous ne les lâcherons pas
merci alors
je partage effectivement le souci
d'égalité et nous partageons en tant que
rapporteur de la commission sociale se
soucis des qualités qui a été
formellement bien formulée par Monsieur
laelec et effectivement on peut on s'est
posé la question il s'avère que en fait
il y en a peu qui ont déjà en ce qui
compte
1000 excuses il y a peu de stagiaires ou
de trucs qui sont déjà partis à la
retraite du fait de l'âge et on a
travaillé à une éventuelle rétroactivité
de la mesure mais ça paraît très
difficile ces pensions sont liquidées
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
n'avons pas donné suite à cette
réflexion mais avis défavorable bien sûr
sur le rapport
mais la vie
alors nous avons un amendement
2917 rectifié madame Ferré merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre alors la pédagogie c'est l'art
de la répétition donc je vais répéter
vous avez décidé de vitaliser la
fonction parlementaire par l'addition de
toutes les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
entre vos mains d'une droite coalisée
mais nous ne sommes pas dupe les
Français non plus et ils vous le
rediront encore cet après-midi et nous
ne lâcherons rien comme nous lâcherons
rien voilà ce que nous voulons vous dire
inlassablement amendement après
amendement celui-ci présenté vise à
demander au gouvernement un rapport qui
permettra de faire un bilan sur les
oubliés de la retraite les bénéficiaires
de turc notamment et le dispositif
assimilable mais nous nous l'aurons pas
si le gouvernement a décidé de reprendre
les dispositions préconisées par la
Mission flash des collègues députés cela
n'atténue en rien l'injustice de cette
réforme il vient cet proposition vient
effectivement combler un vide juridique
mais ce sera comme je l'ai déjà dit deux
ans de plus qui seront demandés à ces
personnes pour pouvoir prendre leur
retraite cette proposition de l'eau une
proposition pardon de loin sur le sujet
des bénéficiaires des tucs étaient
pourtant prêtes et pouvait être choisi
comme véhicule législatif sans passer
par l'injustice de réforme des retraites
voilà l'objet de notre amendement
rappeler encore et à nouveau que votre
réforme est injuste qu'elle a été dans
un premier temps à l'égard de ses
anciens tucs les tukistes comme on les
appelait celles et ceux qui ont été
recrutés dans les années 80 qui
aujourd'hui ont droit à la retraite mais
demain vous l'entendrez comme à tous de
travailler deux ans de plus heureusement
que eux aussi ont rien lâché ce sont
mobilisés pour qu'il n'y ait une petite
reconnaissance de cet engagement et des
efforts qu'ils avaient fait en direction
des associations et des collectivités
locales à l'époque
avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur nous sommes toujours en
direct sur l'antenne de Public Sénat la
chaîne qui vous fait vivre ses débats
sur la réforme des retraites au dixième
jour de ses débats j'accueilli ici
Sophie primat bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice LRD également présidente de la
commission des affaires économiques du
Sénat 1 mot sur ce qui se joue depuis
maintenant une heure et demie cette
gauche c'est l'intérieur qui répète le
même paragraphe en ouverture de ces
prises de parole qui dénoncent la
dévitalisation du du débat parlementaire
qui dénonce aussi une droite coalisée
avec le gouvernement et le fait qu'il ne
lâcheront rien qu'est ce que ça vous
avez que vous que ce comique de
répétition en tout cas cette répétition
dans l'hémicycle oui c'est un comique
tout à fait relatif et en fait c'est pas
oh ça nous fait plus rire non du tout au
début ça nous a fait rire un peu moi je
tiens à rappeler alors pas de façon très
académique parce qu'on n'a pas la parole
le paradoxe situation c'est que la
droite n'a pas la parole vous voyez
qu'on prend très rarement la parole donc
je rappelle votre rapport la parole pour
euh je rappelle sans cesse que si nous
sommes dans cette situation c'est de
leur responsabilité c'est leur
comportement qui est amené cette
procédure et on voit bien d'ailleurs que
le débat c'est un débat qui d'ailleurs
est intéressant parce que dans le fond
quand il présente leurs amendements et
ils présentent tout leurs amendements il
y a des arguments qui sont intéressants
alors
là on est sur les travaux d'utilité
collective sur les tucs il y a des
choses intéressantes dans leur propre
parce que d'abord on peut pas avoir des
amendements dans tous les sens mais ce
sont des sujets qui sont importants
alors ils demandent des rapports moi je
leur suggère de faire leur travail de
parlementaire de faire le contrôle et de
faire eux-mêmes d'ailleurs mais ce sont
des sujets qui sont intéressants et qui
méritent que l'on s'y penche mais ce
qu'on se dit c'est qu'on est à la 7e
journée syndicale eux ils sont des
sénateurs de gauche ils se veulent les
relais de cette mobilisation dans dans
la rue ça peut être aussi légitime
politique mais c'est absolument légitime
politiquement d'avoir un vrai débat or
leur comportement a amené à un nom débat
et c'est pour ça que je le regrette et
c'est pour ça que je prends un peu
éligititivement la parole dans les
musiques pour redire que c'est dommage
que cette situation qu'ils ont eux-mêmes
créées ne permettent pas un véritable
débat alors nous sommes au 10e jour de
l'examen de la réforme des retraites au
Sénat on voit qu'il y a encore plusieurs
centaines d'amendements à examiner si on
souhaite terminer sur un vote d'ici
demain minuit est-ce que c'est jouable
selon vous je pense que si nos débats
continuent à nous débats les
présentations des amendements continuent
à ce rythme là on devrait pouvoir y
arriver avant demain soir minuit oui je
pense qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez c'est
que le vote de cette réforme des
retraites puisse envoyer un signal aussi
à l'intersyndical et que ils arrêtent
leur mouvement je me permettrai pas de
dire ça à l'intersyndicale je pense que
il y a un temps parlementaire ce temps
parlementaire va se terminer non pas
demain soir il restera encore la
commission mix paritaire et
éventuellement un chacune des assemblées
en revanche je pense qu'une fois que ici
les choses seront passées au Sénat que
le Sénat aura donné sa position
peut-être qu'un dialogue avec
l'intersyndical peut se faire pourquoi
un dialogue avec un syndical si le texte
est voté il y a plus grand chose à
négocier il y a des mesures
réglementaires qui peuvent être mises en
place parce que il y a un certain nombre
de choses qui peuvent être discutées
d'ici la CMP je crois que tout le monde
est prêt au dialogue et pas à
l'embrasement il faudrait qu'il y ait un
nouveau dialogue avec les syndicats
entre aujourd'hui et la CMP bah moi je
pense que le gouvernement et la droite
sénatoriale qui vous savez à voter cette
cette réforme bien avant que le
gouvernement
reste toujours à l'écoute les
parlementaires doivent être à l'écoute
c'est pour ça que je regrette cette
pantomine aujourd'hui ici j'ai une
dernière question parce que ça va dans
l'importance sur la suite des débats
puisque il y a un amendement sur
l'accélération de la de la clause du
grand-père dans les régimes spéciaux un
amendement qui a été déposé par votre
chef de fil Bruno Retailleau et qui doit
être examiné dans les prochaines heures
si cet amendement qui n'est pas dans le
vote unique qui n'est donc pas dans le
vote bloqué si avant on n'est pas
descendu ça ferait tomber des des
plusieurs dizaines voire une grosse
centaine de sous amendements de la
gauche qu'est-ce qui peut se passer
autour de cette amendement au taillot
selon vous il revient au président
Retailleau de prendre sa décision moi je
ne suis pas le président Retailleau il y
aura une réflexion de sa part entre le
message politique qu'il souhaite
adresser qui est un message un marqueur
politique particulièrement de notre
partie les républicains et puis
l'efficacité de nos débats bien merci
merci Sophie prima alors pour tout
comprendre ce dont on vient de parler là
sur l'amendement de Retailleau monsieur
rataillon on va aller en dans
l'hémicycle en tribune de presse
retrouver Audrey vuettaz je l'ai
expliqué mais un peu rapidement Audrey
qu'est-ce qui se joue exactement autour
de cet amendement Retailleau et bien
Quentin d'abord un petit point d'étapes
il reste un peu plus de 600 amendements
à examiner à raison de deux minutes par
amendement quand on fait un calcul un
peu grossier il reste une vingtaine
d'heures de débats mais il pourrait y
avoir vous l'avez dit une accélération
aujourd'hui pourquoi parce qu'après
l'article 13 il y a un amendement porté
par le patron des LR Bruno Retailleau
soutenu aussi par certains sénateurs LR
qui prévoit d'accélérer la fin des
régimes spéciaux d'ici 2040 mais cet
amendement n'a pas été retenu dans le
vote final par le gouvernement la droite
a donc deux options soit elle décide
tout de même de défendre cet amendement
pendant 2 minutes pour expliquer sa
vision expliquer son propos ou alors
elle le retire puisqu'il ne figurera pas
dans le texte final dans le vote final
et qu'il n'a pas été sélectionné par le
gouvernement sauf que si la droite
décide de retirer cet amendement ça fait
tomber des facto 300 amendements de la
gauche qui lui était relié quand on
parle de 600 amendements à examiner
encore et qu'on en fait tomber 300 vous
le voyez ce n'est pas sans conséquence
loin de là merci Audrey pour toutes ces
explications et on le voit c'est l'un
des enjeux des prochaines heures cet
amendement Retailleau qui devrait être
examiné après l'article 13 et qui
pourrait avoir de grandes conséquences
sur le rythme ensuite des débats
retournant l'hémicycle vous n'êtes pas
dupe nous ne sommes pas nuls avis
défavorable
monsieur le ministre mon avis même
raison c'est le président merci
nous passons suivant
rectifié qui le présente monsieur le
Président Gontard
merci monsieur le Président
j'avais une question à poser à ce moment
des débats pourquoi avez-vous décidé de
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement vous espériez sans doute que
nous laissions la retraite des Français
entre les mains des droits de coalisées
nous ne sommes pas dupe les Français non
plus nous ne lâcherons rien nous ne les
lâcherons pas et nous ne lâcherons pas
non plus avec ma collègue Mélanie Vogel
les Français de l'étranger
il s'agit d'une demande de rapport
étudiant la possibilité de calculer le
salaire annuel moyen au prorata des
années travaillées en France afin de
mettre fin au traitement inégal des
personnes ayant travaillé à l'étranger
les Françaises des Français étrangers
n'ont souvent pas travaillé 25 ans en
France or cette règle des 25 ans ne
produit pas les mêmes effets avantageux
pour une personne qui a travaillé moins
de 25 ans en France dans les faits
toutes les années travaillées en France
sont prises en compte y compris avec un
revenu particulièrement bas il s'agit
par exemple d'aller d'études pendant
lesquelles l'assuré avait un employé
rémunéré à 100 euros il s'agit également
de l'année en cours de laquelle l'assuré
est parti à l'étranger et dont le revenu
annuel français est donc
particulièrement faible puisque ces
années tirent ensuite le salaire annuel
moyen vers le bas les Français et
Français de l'étranger sont pénalisés au
moment du calcul de leur retraite il
s'agit donc d'une rupture d'égalité que
rien ne justifie la conséquence évidente
serait de mettre fin à cette rupture
d'égalité désavantageant les Français
avec une carrière internationale pour ce
faire il suffirait par exemple de
calculer le salaire annuel moyen à
partir de 60% des meilleurs années
travaillées en France autrement dit au
lieu d'utiliser un nombre absolu
d'années le nombre d'années prises en
compte serait proratisé en fonction de
la durée de la carrière française donc
effectivement il s'agit d'un rapport on
aurait évidemment préféré
proposer autre chose mais ça n'a pas été
ça n'a pas été possible mais je suis sûr
que cette idée pourrait être prise par
Monsieur le Ministre alors monsieur le
rapporteur
même à vie défavorable et nous passons
toujours après l'article 11
11 amendements qui vont faire l'objet
d'une discussion commune madame Justin
guidez oui merci monsieur le Président
c'est un moment vise à valoriser
l'engagement des sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires pour leur retraite leur
mission sont exercées dans des
situations de tension et de risques
inhérents à leur activité auquel
viennent s'ajouter les contraintes
professionnelles à cet égard la
reconnaissance de la valorisation de
leur engagement sont un devoir pour ses
représentants d'une société plus
solidaire et engagée le présent
amendement prévoit donc que leur
engagement soit valorisé au bout de 10
années de service par l'attribution de
trimestres pris en compte dans le calcul
de leur pension ces trimestre sont
vocation de compléter le cas échéant la
carrière professionnelle des
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires afin de
faciliter un départ à taux plein à la
retraite les limites et conditions
d'octroi de ces trimestres
supplémentaires seront définies par
décrées en Conseil d'État ce décret
prévoira notamment un octroi de trois
trimestres à compter de 10 années
d'engagement puis au délai de un trim
réglementaires tous les 5 ans cette
mesure vient en complément à la
revalorisation de la nouvelle prestation
de fidélisation et de reconnaissance
sous la précédente législature celle-ci
a en effet été étendu par la création
d'un nouveau seuil d'éligibilité de 15
ans d'engagement au lieu de 20 ans de 10
ans en cas d'invalidité opérationnelle
reconnue musicalement et
significativement revalorisé au 1er
janvier 2023 elle est aujourd'hui de 500
euros à 3000 euros par an contre
auparavant entre 400 à 2000 euros par an
selon la durée d'engagement
je vous remercie
madame la Présidente Nathalie de Lattre
le Président mes chers collègues il y a
quelques articles
nous rien lâcher
sur la retraite des sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels et notamment avec le
centre et la droite et nous avec la vie
favorable du Gouvernement non ne
lâcherons rien non plus avec la vie
favorable du Gouvernement avec le centre
et la droite sur la retraite des
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires c'est
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires que je
voudrais saluer parce qu'ils sont venus
en renfort cet été notamment sur la
Gironde et de nombreux départements pour
sauver nos maisons pour sauver nos biens
pour sauver nos animaux pour sauver nos
forêts donc c'est un moyen de les saluer
cet amendement vise à la reconnaissance
nationale pour leur engagement ils vise
donc à instaurer une bonification sous
la forme de l'attribution de trois
trimestres au bout de 10 ans
d'engagement cette bonification est
complétée par un trimestre
supplémentaire tous les 5 ans elle ne
pourra conduire à valider davantage que
quatre trimestres par année civile nous
non plus nous ne lâchons pas les
Français
un amendement 120
rectifier
oui merci monsieur le Président le
groupe Union centriste a largement
consigné cet amendement en faveur des
sapeurs-pompiers et donc il a été
salement défendu par notre collègue
Nathalie delalattre merci merci
215 rectifié
un abonnement monsieur le Président
Patriat 1904 rectifié et monsieur le
Président merci l'opposition
dévitaliser totalement la fonction
parlementaire en faisant en sorte par
des armoires répétitifs de bloquer le
débat et de faire en sorte que le Sénat
s'auto détruise on ne votant pas un
texte de loi en faisant tout pour
sélectionner l'opposition à utiliser
tous les moyens qui étaient à se poser
position pour pour pouvoir bloquer ce
débat donc nous ne lâcherons rien non
plus mais pour ce qui vous concerne il y
a longtemps que le peuple vous a lâché
alors c'est amendement et bien alors cet
amendement ils disent aujourd'hui à une
reconnaissance des sapeurs-pompiers pour
leur donner trois trimestres
supplémentaires au bout de 10 ans
d'exercices et un trimestre
supplémentaire ensuite par décret il a
été défendu auparavant donc je ne
reviens pas sur cet amendement de
défendons aussi tout à fait merci
l'amendement 2339 rectifié madame
pomirol
merci monsieur le Président
amendement concerne également les
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires et je
voulais vous dire que nous connaissons
tous bien les sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires nous les soutenons tous vous
n'êtes pas les seuls et loin de là à les
défendre vous savez ces hommes et ces
femmes qui s'engagent avec courage et
dévouement pour la sécurité de nos
concitoyens au service du public qui
l'engagement qui les au nord et il ne
lâche pas la population nous ne les
lâcherons pas nous non plus même si vous
avez décidé de dévitaliser la fonction
parlementaire par l'addition de toutes
les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous ne serions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droits de coalisées nous ne sommes
pas dupe et les Français non plus nous
ne lâcherons rien nous ne lâcherons pas
et nous ne lâcherons pas donc nos
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires en
demandant donc une majoration de la
durée d'assurance une bonification pour
la retraite trois trimestres pour 10 ans
un trimestre pour 5 ans supplémentaires
au titre de la solidarité nationale un
terme extrêmement important pour nous et
pour eux c'est sous amendement prévoit
également un droit d'option qui permette
au FPV concernés de choisir entre les
bénéfices de cette bonification ou celui
de la prestation de la fidélisation et
de reconnaissance ou plutôt la nouvelle
prestation de fidélisation et de
reconnaissance à laquelle il pourrait
prétendre
merci l'amendement 3415
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président alors
effectivement les
sapiens volontaire bénéficient depuis
cette année d'une revalorisation du
barème de la nouvelle prestation de
fidélisation et de haute connaissance
qui permet de garantir une rente versée
après sa cession d'activité pour ceux
ayant accompli une durée minimale de
service effectif nous allons dans le
sens de ces dispositions puisque le
présent amendement prévoit
l'instauration d'une bonification sous
la forme de l'attribution de trois
trimestres au bout de 10 ans
d'engagement cette bonification est
complétée d'un trimestre sous les 5 ans
elle ne pourra conduire à valider
davantage que quatre trimestres par an
je j'aurais aimé là on aurait pu inviter
de notre assemblée en débattre largement
quand même puisque nous semble il semble
que nous soyons d'accord parce que mais
vous avez décidé le droit d'amendement
je voudrais dire que le droit
d'amendement vit essentiellement par
l'explication de vote et c'est le droit
d'amendement l'esprit du droit
d'amendement que vous bafouez vous et la
droite et le gouvernement un abonnement
il se comme je fais actuellement le
ministre répond le rapporteur répond et
nous nous pouvons pas l'explication de
vote voire modifier notre choix ou le
retirer etc
nous expliquons notre vote quand vous
nous empêchez de d'expliquer notre vote
il faut savoir que vous bafouez que vous
empêchez le droit le droit essentiel
essentiel le droit à l'amendement c'est
c'est ça que je comptais dire j'aurais
pu dire aussi que vous avez décidé de
débitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'indice par l'addition de toutes
les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement voilà
merci
un amendement de 1914 de 1913 rectifié
bis monsieur le Président Kader
non
merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues nos pompiers
régulièrement appelés soldat du feu ont
connu une mobilisation exceptionnelle
vous le savez l'été dernier je vous
rappelle en août 2022 il y avait plus de
62000 hectares brûlés Gironde
Bouches-du-Rhône Bretagne plus aucun
territoire n'était épargné vous vous
souvenez les scènes de vacanciers
évacués dans les conditions terribles
tout l'été ce sont des milliers de
pompiers volontaires et professionnels
qui se sont battus contre les flammes à
travers la France des renforts de
pompiers Grecs Autrichiens ou allemands
ou même étaient nécessaires et donc il
faut que nos pompiers soient plus
nombreux et ces défis face au
réchauffement climatique doivent se
concrétiser par des recrutements de deux
pompiers ils sont donc nous n'ayons pas
complètement mesuré les moyens
nécessaires en l'espèce et dans ce cadre
dans ce cas de monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues il est vraiment
regrettable que vous y ait décidé de
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
qui vous offrent que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laisserions
la retraite entre les mains des droits
de coalisées mais nous ne sommes pas
dupes et les Français non plus donc nous
ne lâcherons rien et nous ne lâcherons
pas les pompiers la hauteur des enjeux
nous oblige à recrutement complémentaire
indispensables le danger et les aspects
difficiles de ce métier n'aide pas à
suscité l'évocation sans pompiers
bénévoles la sécurité incendie de nos
concitoyens ne pourrait être rassurés
alors que plusieurs millions de français
bénéficient de cette sécurité alors mes
chers collègues cette bonification de
trimestre qui est sous-entendue dans cet
amendement devrait permettre et se
renfort de recrutement et il est évident
qu'il nous faut l'évaluer et c'est pour
cela que nous souhaitons l'émission d'un
rapport permettant de bien mesurer donc
les impacts de cette mesure qui me
semble juste pour des
serviteur de la nation que tout le monde
ici soutient avec force et vigueur merci
monsieur le Président un abonnement
3748 rectifiés monsieur ferdenic le
présente
monsieur le ministre chers collègues à
ce jour on sait qu'une activité bénévole
ne peut être prise en compte dans le
calcul de la retraite les revenus qui
sont versés à ce titre ne constitue pas
une rémunération en proven en parler
mais une indemnisation exonérée tout
prélèvement social les sapeurs-pompiers
bénévoles ne cotisent donc pas pour leur
retraite et aucun trimestre ne peut le
être allouer à ce titre pourtant c'est
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires tout comme
les professionnels vont intervenir dans
le cadre d'opération de secours à des
personnes de protection de bien de
l'environnement d'extinction des
incendies cette activité de bénévolat
présente de forts risques pour la
sécurité et la santé des personnes qui
s'y engagent surtout les services
départementaux d'incendie et de secours
seraient réduits à pas grand chose sans
les sapeurs-pompiers volontaires il y en
a
251900 sapeurs-pompiers volontaires en
tout sapeurs-pompiers dont 78% de
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires 17% de
professionnels auxquels on ajoute les
pompiers militaires 5% des effectifs ils
sont ils semblent donc utile d'étudier
l'opportunité la faisabilité le coût
d'une modification pour la retraite des
trimestres des bénévolats des
sapeurs-pompiers nous ne lâcherons rien
même là-dessus vous espériez sans doute
que nous laisserions la retraite des
Français entre les mains des droits de
Colisée vous avez décidé de dévitaliser
la fonction parlementaire par l'addition
de tous les procédés que vous offre la
Constitution et notre Règlement les
Français ne sont pas dupe nous non plus
nous ne les lâcherons pas
alors la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
vous qui ne voulait rien lâcher mais je
vous demanderai quand même de lâcher
votre amendement de 1913
au bénéfice des amendements 85 120 215
1904 de 1339 3101 3415 4732 tout
s'identique il s'agit là des
sapeurs-pompiers une juste
reconnaissance trop tardive bien sûr
mais qui est tout à fait
légitime de prendre en compte merci en
tout cas le monsieur le ministre d'avoir
fait en sorte de couvrir couvrir sur le
plan financier cet engagement puisque
cette bonification était attendue depuis
un certain nombre d'années et en
conséquence je donne un avis favorable à
ces amendements par contre
pour un problème logistique légistique
pardon l'amendement 1936
n'est pas le le meilleur pour être
repris ce sont les autres qui seront
repris quant aux amendements de 1913 de
Monsieur canner et 3748 ce sont des
demandes de rapport et je pense qu'il
serait plus judicieux de les retirer
merci
la vie du gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président la ville du
Gouvernement est favorable sur les
amendements 1904 rectifié bis tel que
présenté par le président Patriat 85120
215 23 39 31 01 34 15 et 47 32 sont les
amendements qui recueillent favorable de
monsieur le rapporteur je précise que
cette valorisation trimestre vient en
appui et en complément de la
revalorisation de la nouvelle prime des
fidélité de reconnaissance à la suite de
l'adoption par votre assemblée comme par
l'Assemblée nationale de la loi dite
matrast il est maintenant quelques mois
c'est donc une juste reconnaissance
c'est une demande de retrait pour le 19
36 29 13 et 37 48 merci ils sont
maintenus
il est presque 11h30 sur l'antenne de
Public Sénat nous sommes en direct sur
notre antenne la chaîne qui vous fait
vivre tous ces débats sur la réforme des
retraites notamment cette dernière ligne
droite dans ces échanges on va rejoindre
notre journaliste journaliste Audrey
vous êtes en tribune de presse Audrey un
petit mot sur ce qui s'est passé depuis
9h30 nous avons commencé à l'article 10
pouvez nous faire un petit résumé des
débats depuis ce matin oui et nous en
sommes à la fin de l'article 11 et il y
a deux choses à retenir sur cette
article 11 deux apports du Sénat la
chambre des territoires le Sénat permet
donc aux élus de cotiser sur leur sur
leur indemnités pour leur retraite et de
racheter s'il le souhaite des trimestres
lorsqu'ils d'exercer un mandat et à
l'instant le Sénat vient aussi d'acter
la possibilité pour les pompiers
volontaires d'obtenir quelques
trimestres supplémentaires pour leur
investissement jeudi deux apports du car
ce sont deux points qui ont été retenus
par le gouvernement dans le vote final
qui figureront donc au moment du vote
final et puis des débats qui sont
marqués ce matin par de très nombreuses
prises de parole à gauche puisque les
sénateurs de gauche ont le droit de
défendre leurs amendements des prises de
parole qui commencent ou qui sont toutes
ponctués par la même phrase qui se
répète à l'envie à chaque sénateur la
reprend dans ses mots ça commence en
disant vous dévitalisez le départ par le
montant critique des fêtes au
gouvernement et à la majorité
sénatoriale de droits des articles qui
ont été utilisés pour contraindre les
débats et puis ça se termine en disant
nous défendrons les Français nous ne
lâcherons rien et ça commence un petit
peu à agacer dans les dans les rangs de
la droite et de la majorité
présidentielle tout à l'heure le
sénateur François Patriat qui appartient
à la majorité présidentielle après la
parole en disant vous n'avez pas
l'apanage de la défense des Français oui
Audrey on avance vers l'article 12 c'est
un article important oui il y a de
l'enjeu sur cet article 12 parce que ça
concerne la retraite des aidants c'est
un sujet qui est porté de longue date
par la droite sénatoriale notamment pour
l'instant il n'existait pas de
dispositif particulier pour ces aidants
ça concerne 60 000 personnes vous le
voyez des débats qui devraient être
intéressants sur ce sujet voilà merci
Audrey Public Sénat qui ne lâche rien
dans le suivi en direct de l'examen de
la réforme des retraites jusqu'au vote
finale vous avez décidé de
d'éviter le commentaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement vous espériez sans doute que
nous laissions la retraite des Français
entre les mains des droites coalisées
nous ne sommes pas dupe les Français non
plus nous ne lâcherons rien et surtout
nous ne lâcherons pas les Français et
c'est pour cette raison que je voudrais
dire sur cet article que bien évidemment
l'objectif de créer une assurance
vieillesse pour les aidants est un
objectif tout à fait louable mais que
vous survendez et c'est le problème
fondamental de ce texte vous survendez
quelques mesures positives aux Français
qui ne font pas le poids absolument pas
le poids par rapport au recul de l'âge
de la retraite de deux ans
les mesures qui sont contenues dans cet
article 12 vont vraisemblablement
concernés une quarantaine de mille
personnes alors qu'il y a en France 11
millions de nos concitoyens qui prennent
en charge des enfants des personnes
handicapées qu'ils soient très proches
ou plus éloignés or on sait que cette
mission contribue à ce que certains
doivent abandonner leur carrière
professionnelle voir refuser des
évolutions de carrière et que ça a un
impact évidemment terrible sur l'âge de
départ à la retraite et le niveau des
pensions de retraite enfin je voudrais
dire à notre collègue patria qui a dû
s'absenter que si nous sommes
minoritaires ici au Sénat nous sommes
majoritaires dans le pays avec les
millions de nos concitoyens qui vont
encore le dire aujourd'hui et qui très
massivement s'oppose à cette réforme de
retraite et donc ne croyez pas qu'ici
vous représentiez le peuple français il
vous le redira dans la rue cet
après-midi monsieur ferder
solidarité territoire et je suis avec le
principal intéressé bonjour François
Patriat président du groupe de la
majorité présidentielle ici au Sénat où
vous entendez votre collègue brûlant
chez les communistes et qui qui vous dit
qu'il faut que vous entendiez cette
mobilisation cette septième journée
mobilisation que c'est ça le message du
peuple oui ce que j'entends actuellement
depuis les heures et les heures que je
passe au Sénat depuis le 2 et de la
répétition d'arguments permanence
souvent d'arguments qui vont contre la
vérité la réalité de la loi mais pour ce
qui nous concerne bien entendu moi je
suis attentif à toutes les
manifestations qui ont eu lieu depuis le
mois de janvier chaque fois j'ai écouté
ce que disait à la fois les manifestants
mais aussi ce que disait les syndicats
que j'ai rencontrés pour certains donc
j'ai pu appeler avec eux donc on peut
pas dire aujourd'hui que le gouvernement
à la fois surprise ni ignorent que dit
la rue pas du tout vous avez vu ce que
fait à la gauche sénatoriale elle répète
le même message avec ces trois éléments
de langage il y a une dévitalisation du
débat parlementaire avec notamment
l'utilisation du 44 3 de la Constitution
que il y a une forme de coalition des
droites et il vous mette dans cette
coalition et aussi qui ne lâcheront rien
qu'est-ce que vous répondez assez assez
parlementaire de la gauche sénatorielle
qui répète ce message alors d'abord qui
a dévitalisé la fonction parlementaire
on va pas se renvoyer la balle mais
regardons
la chronologie des fêtes l'affiliation
depuis le 2 chaque jour l'opposition à
utiliser tous les moyens de partir que
lui permet le règlement pour bloquer le
débat et elle dénature la fonction du
Parlement en faisant en sorte par ces
manœuvres réitérer de faire en sorte que
le Sénat au bout du compte ne vote pas
leur objectif c'est que nous débattions
sans voter est-ce que c'est pas ça qui
aujourd'hui dévitalisent le Parlement ça
c'est sur la première élément de langage
le second c'est sur le fait que il y
aurait une coalition entre la droite le
centre est maintenant Renaissance
écoutez il semble que ce texte a été
présenté par le gouvernement il a été
proposé par le chef de l'État pendant la
campagne électorale il a été réitérer
dans les rencontres que le président a
eu avec les syndicats ou la CGT n'est
pas venue d'ailleurs on refusé de venir
aujourd'hui elle demande une audience
mais elle n'est pas venue quand elle a
été invitée elle est pas venue non plus
au CNR quand il a été invité et on est
donc dans notre scénario
l'anglais rencontre ont eu lieu où
effectivement le gouvernement des a
entendu donc on ne peut pas nous
reprocher aujourd'hui de d'aller sur un
texte qui est celui du gouvernement
c'est celui du gouvernement quand on est
dans une situation de majorité relative
pour faire pâté un texte il faut trouver
des alliés nous avons trouvé des alliés
avec la gauche quand il s'est agit du
texte de loi sur les énergies
renouvelables donc pour trouver
une majorité
va leur permettre le droit de grève est
maintenu mais je crois que j'ai vu ce
matin on le fait tout le monde
descendage que
90% des Français étaient convaincus que
la loi serait votée et appliquée dans un
pays l'État de droit quand de la loi est
votée on peut la contester avant quand
elle est votée elle est votée elle
s'applique à tous cette réforme vous
êtes très proche du chef de l'État vous
avez été parmi ces tout premier soutien
des 2016 qu'est-ce que vous savez de son
état display actuellement
écoutez je l'ai rencontré mais on n'est
pas parlé de la réforme des retraites je
vais le rencontrer quelques instants
avant-hier à l'hommage qu'il a rendu
très bel hommage qu'il a rendu à viser
la Ligny on a paru déterminé il nous a
dit de tenir bon on nous a dit qu'il
fallait qu'on soit sur ce sur la ligne
qui a été qui essaie du gouvernement
aujourd'hui d'aboutir à un texte
équilibré et juste ce que je crois
aujourd'hui c'est un texte qui à la fois
demande des efforts aux Français c'est
vrai nous en sommes bien convaincus et
nous savons que c'est difficile mais
dans le même temps qu'il y a porté les
avancées que aucune aucun texte de loi
sur les retraites auparavant n'avait
apporté merci François Patriat pour
cette
on retourne dans l'hémicycle ou c'est
Guillaume Gontard qui a la parole huit
mois contre 4 pour les hommes de
génération de 1980 de 1980 pardon c'est
évidemment inadmissible alors que la
situation des femmes est déjà compliquée
puisque 40 % d'entre elles partent à
leur retraite avec une carrière
incomplète et que 20 % d'entre elles
attendent l'annulation automatique de la
décote à 67 ans pour partir à la
retraite contre 10% pour les hommes
votre réforme va aggraver cette
situation au lieu de l'améliorer tous
ces mensonges nous poussent à proposer
cet amendement pour associer le Conseil
d'État à l'écriture des décrets car ce
gouvernement n'est pas digne de
confiance et méprise le peuple français
en bâillonnant le Parlement avec le 47
ans ici article 38 article 42 ensuite le
44 2 le 44 3 l'arme des faibles pour
empêcher le débat autour de cette
réforme injuste
alors un amendement de Monsieur
avis du gouvernement
avis de la commission du gouvernement la
commission
défavorable défavorable alors un
amendement 2164 de précision
rédactionnelle que vous aviez déjà
annoncé
favorable du Gouvernement un amendement
25-46 monsieur le Président routard
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
je vais me répéter mais je pense qu'il
faut se répéter vous avez décidé de
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de tous les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement vous espériez sans doute que
nous laissions la retraite des Français
entre les mains des droits de coalisées
nous ne sommes pas dupe les Français non
plus nous ne lâcherons rien nous ne
lâcherons pas
nous avons pu depuis le début de
l'examen de cette réforme cité les
nombreux mensonges et incohérences que
ce gouvernement et notamment sur
l'impact de la réforme sur la retraite
des femmes la retraite à 1200 euros pour
tous ou encore le fait que cette réforme
serait inéluctable un autre argument que
nous entendons en boucle dans toutes les
interviews depuis le 10 janvier le
problème démographique que connaîtrait
notre pays et qui rendrait cette réforme
obligatoire pour sauver notre système de
retraite par répartition premièrement si
le ratio actif retraité s'est
effectivement réduit puisqu'il est passé
de trois actifs par retraités à 1,7
actif par retraité notre système à
continuer à tenir solidement notamment
par une hausse des cotisations payées
par les salaires que vous refusez de
plus vous refusez aujourd'hui
d'augmenter les salaires alors même que
le système par répartition repose sur
l'idée que la progression des salaires
permettra d'amortir le vieillissement de
la population donc cette réforme révèle
deux choses importantes premièrement ce
gouvernement refuse de soutenir la
hausse des salaires et leur indexation
sur alors que cela permettrait de
résoudre en grande partie le problème du
futur déficit du système des retraites
deuxièmement vous abandonnez l'idée
d'une accélération de la productivité
alors même que toutes les aides et les
exonérations des cotisations que vous
offrez aux entreprises ont justement
pour but d'accélérer cette productivité
elle est comprendre quelque chose ce
sont ces incohérences qui nous poussent
aujourd'hui à déposer sa tassement pour
le compte que le Conseil d'État soit
consulté sur la rédaction de tous ces
décrets importants merci alors l'avis de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable défavorable
défavorable aussi
4591 monsieur ferdin oui merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le mini chers
collègues les auteurs de cet amendement
souhaite que les décisions réglementées
en matière d'incapacité d'enfants ou
d'adulte nécessitant la présence d'un
don qui puisse avoir des droits soient
accompagnés d'un éclairage des instances
représentatives des personnes en
situation de handicap selon le baromètre
2017 de la Fondation April et BVA 11
millions d'énormes familiaux soient un
français sur 6 accompagne au quotidien
proche en situation de dépendance en
raison de son âge d'une maladie ou d'un
handicap des chiffres en constante
augmentation
l'affiliation à l'assurance vieillesse
pour les aidants permet à l'aide en
familiales de valider les trimestres
pour sa retraite sans qu'il ait besoin
de verser des cotisations auprès de sa
caisse de retraite des diagnostics
largement convergents montrent qu'il est
nécessaire de mettre en place un
véritable statut du proche aidant qui
lui confère un certain nombre de droits
plus complet mieux identifié parmi
lesquels des droits revus en matière de
cotisation à la retraite notamment il
s'agirait de revoir quel taux
d'incapacité d'un enfant d'un adulte
nécessite son accompagnement au
quotidien par des aidants c'est pourquoi
dans un souci de plus grande justice
sociale concernant ces situations les
auteurs de cet amendement proposent que
ces taux d'incapacité soit fixés certes
par des crèmes et après consultation des
instances représentatives des personnes
en situation de handicap mais je crains
que nous ne puissions pas le voter parce
que vous avez décidé de dévitaliser la
fonction parlementaire par l'addition de
toutes les procédures que vous offre la
Constitution le règlement vous espériez
sans doute que nous laissions la
retraite des Français entre les mains
des droits de coalisées nous ne sommes
pas dupes les Français non plus nous ne
lâcherons rien nous ne les lâcherons pas
alors monsieur le rapporteur
les odeurs d'enfants en situation de
handicap
il y a une amélioration qui est faite
notamment puisque c'est systématiquement
que ceux qui ont les conditions
d'octroi de la location d'éducation de
l'enfant handicapés puissent rentrer
dans le dispositif aval et dispositions
ont été prises pour que ce soit alignés
les instances de concertation sont
importantes mais nous pensons que c'est
plutôt en aval qu'il faut les faire donc
avis défavorable
le gouvernement le même avis nous allons
maintenant examiner quatre abonnements
identiques madame Pentel merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues en France 8 à 11
millions de personnes soutiennent au
quotidien un proche en perte d'autonomie
ou en situation de handicap ces aidants
sont bien souvent conduits à interrompre
leur carrière professionnelle ce qui a
un impact sur les droits à la retraite
du fait d'une interruption ou d'une
réduction de leur activité aujourd'hui
l'assurance vieillesse des parents au
foyer permet de prendre en compte au
titre de l'assurance vieillesse les
périodes d'interruption ou de réduction
de l'activité professionnelle consacrée
à l'éducation des enfants ou à la prise
en charge d'un proche en situation de
handicap ou en perte d'autonomie
ce dispositif souffre toutefois d'un
défaut de lisibilité et d'homogénéité
aussi nous nous félicitons de
restauration d'une assurance vieillesse
pour les aidants afin de reconnaître les
efforts que ces personnes fournissent au
quotidien et de leur ouvrir des droits
sociaux spécifiques lava bénéficiera aux
actuels bénéficiaires de l'assurance
vieillesse des parents au foyer qui
assument la charge d'un enfant ou d'un
proche handicapé et sera par ailleurs
élargi à d'autres publics qui ne
bénéficient pas aujourd'hui de la prise
en compte de leur situation des dames
dans la constitution de leurs droits à
la retraite il s'agit des personnes qui
ne cohabitent pas avec la personne dont
ils assument la charge et avec
lesquelles il ne présentent pas de lien
familiaux étroit ainsi que des parents
d'enfants éligibles en complément
d'allocation d'éducation de l'enfant
handicapés
nous regrettons malgré tout que ce
dispositif ne soit pas ouvert à
l'ensemble des parents d'enfants
handicapés qui perçoivent la location
d'éducation de l'enfant handicapés de
base ces objets de notre amendement je
vous remercie alors un amendement
identique de 1978 madame meunier oui je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure les
associations représentant
le secteur du handicap et la perte de
l'autonomie sont très critiques par
rapport à ce projet de loi et nous
aurions pu en discuter mais vous avez
décidé de dévitaliser la fonction
parlementaire par l'adaptation de toutes
les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
pensiez sûrement être entre vous la
droite réunie mais non nous sommes là
nous ne lâchons rien et nous lâcherons
pas les Françaises et les Français dans
la rue mobilisés contre ce projet
du dispositif là va tel que détaillée à
l'article 12 il s'agit quasiment cela a
été dit d'un duplicata à droit constant
de l'allocation vieillesse proche au
foyer à ce titre le collectif handicap a
rappelé le caractère restrictif de
l'extension au seul aidants des enfants
handicapés percevant le complément à la
location d'éducation des enfants
handicapés c'est-à-dire aux enfants dans
le taux d'incapacité être compris entre
50 et
80%. notre amendement entend réparer
cette restriction et de proposer
l'affiliation à l'assurance vieillesse
des aidants les parents dont l'enfant
perçoit une allocation d'enfants
handicapés inférieure à 50%. il n'est
pas rare en effet que des enfants dans
cette situation même scolarisée à
l'école ordinaire ne puisse pas être
accueilli toute la journée et tous les
jours de la semaine ce sont parfois deux
à trois demi-journées seulement et
l'impact sur l'organisation familiale
est évident et il convenait de le
compenser merci d'abonnement 3326 madame
pour se Monge de présente
merci monsieur le Président alors une
personne sur six était Dante
c'est-à-dire une environ dans une
fourchette de 8 à 11 millions de
Français
37% des aidants sont proches de la
retraite enfin presque proche puisqu'ils
sont âgés de 50 à 64 ans 57 % des
aidants sont des femmes 8 aidants sur 10
on le sentiment de ne pas être
suffisamment soutenu par les pouvoirs
publics monsieur le ministre tous ces
chiffres se combinent à d'autres les
aidants sont des femmes je les dis
majoritairement qui cumulent leur rôle à
celui de leur rôle des Dantes à celui de
leur carrière souvent hachée
l'élargissement de la possibilité de
valider des trimestres à un plus grand
nombre des dents prévus par la tire que
l'article 12 est positif certes mais ces
dispositions restent quand même
malheureusement
trop restrictive et très en deçà à
l'aune de la brutalité de votre réforme
vous auriez pu faire davantage aussi cet
amendement prévoit d'élargir les
critères d'affiliation à l'assurance
vieillesse des aidants en l'ouvrant à
tous les parents d'enfants handicapés
ayant perçu une allocation d'éducation
de l'enfant handicapé de base et donc
pas seulement à ceux et visibles un
complément dans une logique d'ailleurs
deux simplification des démarches et de
l'accès aux droits comme c'était le
collectif aussi qui nous en avait parlé
il aurait été intéressant dans débattre
vous le conviendrez et moi de répondre
peut-être à la réponse de monsieur le
ministre mais vous avez décidé
de dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement et donc du coup nous n'aurons
pas cette explication de vote qui clôt
en général le droit d'amendement donc
il faut conclure bon alors je dirais
nous ne lâcherons pas les Français dans
le débat de la retraite alors madame
Cohen pour l'amendement
208 rectifié
merci monsieur le Président la création
de l'assurance vieillesse des aidants
prévus par cet article 12 ne sera
malheureusement pas débattu par le Sénat
à mon tour de réaffirmer que vous avez
décidé de dévitaliser la fonction
parlementaire par l'addition de toutes
les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Françaises et des
Français entre les mains des droits de
coalisées nous ne sommes pas du tout les
Français non plus nous ne lâcherons rien
nous ne les lâcherons pas les
associations des dents demandent des
changements beaucoup plus profonds en
2021 un français sur 6 s'occupait d'un
procédant et je devrais dire une
française
âgée ou handicapée selon une étude
publiée jeudi 2 février par l'adresse
particulièrement exposé au risque
d'isolement et d'épuisement c'est 9,3
millions d'aidants familiaux mettent
souvent leur vie professionnelle entre
parenthèses pour qu'il ne soit pas léger
au moment de la retraite l'exécutif
souhaite renforcer leurs droits avec la
création d'une assurance vieillesse
président à l'heure actuelle 60000
aidants bénéficient du dispositif
assurance vieillesse du parent au foyer
selon l'étude d'impact cette assurance
vieillesse des aidants doit profiter à
40 000 nouveaux bénéficiaires le
collectif inter-associatif des aidants
familiaux et satisfait de la
reconnaissance de l'impact du relais
dent sur sa carrière mais déplore un
projet insuffisant c'est une réécriture
du dispositif existant les droits sont
identiques un petit peu élargies pour
les nouveaux la vision des aidants est
très orientée handicap et ne prend pas
en compte la situation des personnes
malades ou âgées les associations des
dents regrette également la limitation
de la filiation à l'assurance vieillesse
des aidants notre amendement demande
donc d'étendre l'affiliation à l'AVA à
tous les parents d'un enfant dont le
taux d'incapacité de 50% et des parents
d'un enfant en situation de handicap dès
lors qu'il est exigible à l'allocation
AEH de base je vous remercie
alors
l'amendement avis de la commission
écoutez c'est un sujet d'importance
puisque il s'agirait d'ouvrir un droit
supplémentaire à l'avant pour
les bénéficiaires enfin pour les parents
bénéficient d'un enfant handicapé qui
serait éligible à un complément
d'allocation moi je suis étonné je suis
étonné je vous demanderai mes chers
collègues surtout de ne pas voter cet
amendement parce que si on supprime la
linéaire qui est telle qu'il est mis
dans l'amendement ça veut dire qu'on
supprime le droit on supprime le droit
c'est quand même ça aurait dû vous
interpeller quelque part autre chose
qu'aurait dû vous interpeller si vous
demandez une prestation supplémentaire
vous êtes article 40 donc votre
amendement aurait été irrecevable au tir
de l'article 40 voyez-vous soyez
attentifs
faut être mais vous êtes bâillonné mais
on vous entend beaucoup quand même
surtout
[Applaudissements]
des bâillonnez-vous qu'on vous entendez
peut-être mais bon je veux pas c'est un
sujet sérieux c'est un sujet sérieux
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
demande je c'est la raison pour laquelle
il vaut mieux retirer ses amendements
parce que voyez-vous il va à l'encontre
cette suppression ça va à l'encontre de
ce que vous souhaitez et je sais je sais
ce que vous souhaitez mais il faut pas y
répondre comme cela voilà avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le Président si le
gouvernement a donné un avis défavorable
et donc n'a pas retenu ses amendements
dans le cadre du vote unique c'est pour
deux raisons la première mais elle n'est
pas liée à la volonté des auteurs j'en
suis convaincu c'est que comme l'a dit
monsieur le rapporteur à l'instant
l'adoption ses amendements entraînerait
une dégradation du droit et ça n'est pas
la volonté des auteurs c'est un problème
de légistique la deuxième c'est que si
nous avons fait un lien entre le
complément et l'attribution
l'affiliation à l'assurance vieillesse
pour les aidants c'est parce que
l'attribution du complément est prévue
spécifiquement quand les dons est tenu
d'arrêter son activité professionnelle
ou de la réduire à un point qui empêche
de cotiser à l'assurance vieillesse
classique et le fait d'avoir un proche
particulièrement un enfant avec un taux
d'invalidité important n'a pas de lien
mécanique sur la capacité ou
l'incapacité des parents par exemple ou
de l'aidant à travailler ou à ne pas
travailler évidemment il y a une
prépondérance mais ça n'est pas
mécanique l'attribution du complément
est liée à la rédactivité et c'est la
réactivité qui justifie l'affil iation à
l'assurance vieillesse des aidants c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous sommes
attachés à cette rédaction raison pour
laquelle nous donnons un avis
défavorable à des campus ce problème de
logistique qu'il fallait signaler
bien
ils sont maintenus
trois amendements vont faire l'objet
d'une discussion commune
l'amendement 3116 rectifiées et il est
présenté
par Monsieur Ferro
merci monsieur le Président je présente
cette amendement
en l'absence ce matin de notre collègue
David insuline cet amendement il vise à
supprimer
la décision par décret la définition par
décret du taux d'incapacité permanente
pour les aidants décisions qui
justifiera leur rattachement ou non au
régime général
nous le présentons pour enrichir
l'article 12 mais malheureusement il ne
pourra pas être adopté à moins
d'une reprise par le gouvernement
puisque vous avez décidé de délitaliser
notre fonction parlementaire en
utilisant toutes les procédures qu'offre
la constitution et le règlement en
espérant certainement que nous nous
lasserions et que nous vous laissions la
retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées la droite
sénatoriale qui d'ailleurs sur cette
question des retraites n'a jamais changé
d'avis donnant lui en acte et la droite
Elyséenne présidentielle et ministériel
et en effet monsieur le ministre qui
présente son projet de loi aujourd'hui
lui il a changé d'avis et il serait bien
de le reconnaître et de nous expliquer
pourquoi mais nous ne sommes pas dupe et
je crois que les Français non plus ils
vont encore le montrer et le montrer
longtemps eux les Français ne lâchent
rien alors nous non plus ici nous ne
lâchons rien et nous ne les lâcherons
pas
merci Monsieur le reporter vous avez un
amendement 2165
il est rédactionnel
un amendement
monsieur salmon
tout à fait monsieur le Président merci
donc je vais défendre cet amendement et
si vous voulez bien le suivant
même si il n'est pas en lecture commune
bon bah écoute si c'est toi
ces deux amendements sur l'article 12
demandent à ce que les décisions
réglementaires en matière d'incapacité
d'enfant ou d'adultes et nécessitant la
présence d'un aidant soit accompagné
d'un éclairage des instances
représentatives des personnes en
situation de handicap selon le baromètre
2017 de la Fondation a pris les BVA 11
millions des dents familiaux soit un
français sur six accompagne au quotidien
un proche en situation de dépendance en
raison de son âge d'une maladie ou d'un
handicap ces chiffres sont en constante
augmentation en 2030 les projections
estiment qu'un actif sur 4 sera aidant
mais selon ce même baromètre 54% de ces
personnes aidantes
ignorent encore leur statut des dents
la filiation à l'assurance vieillesse
pour les aidants permet allez dans
familiale de valider des trimestres pour
sa retraite sans qu'il ait besoin de
verser des cotisations auprès de cette
caisse par ailleurs des diagnostics
largement convergents montrent qu'il est
nécessaire de mettre en place un
véritable statut du projet dent un
statut qui nous confère un certain
nombre de droits plus complets et mieux
identifiés et notamment en matière de
cotisation à la retraite il s'agirait de
revoir quel taux d'incapacité permanente
d'un enfant ou d'un adulte nécessite son
accompagnement au quotidien par ses
aidants
c'est pourquoi cette proposition est une
proposition de bon sens qui demande
simplement la consultation des instances
les plus à même de juger du taux
d'incapacité avant une validation par
décret vous invoquez souvent le bon sens
sur les rangs de la droite et vous
auriez sûrement voté cet amendement mais
vous ne le ferez plus voilà manque de
courage merci la vie de la Commission
sur ces trois amendements midi nous
sommes en direct sur l'antenne de
publicaina pour ne rien rater de
l'examen de la réforme des retraites ici
au Sénat on va rejoindre Audrey buttaz
Audrey on a vu toutes ses prises de
parole sur les aidants les parents de
personnes handicapées qu'est-ce qui se
joue dans le texte alors nous en sommes
à l'article 12 du projet de loi et cet
article vise à améliorer l'accès à la
retraite aux aidants parce qu'on le sait
un certain abandonne leur travail pour
s'occuper d'un proche avec cet article
il pourrait bénéficier de trimestres
supplémentaires pour cela actuellement
il y 11 millions d'aidants en France et
seuls 60000 bénéficiaires d'une
allocation pour cela avec ce projet de
loi il pourrait être 40 000 personnes
supplémentaires à pouvoir en bénéficier
pour la gauche ça ne va pas assez loin
mais vous le savez les amendements de la
gauche n'ont pas été retenus dans le
vote finale par le gouvernement et alors
on voit toujours ces prises de parole à
gauche sur ce mot d'ordre qu'il répète à
chaque fois qu'il prenne la parole oui
et ça a peut-être interpellé nos
téléspectateurs depuis tout à l'heure et
puis depuis hier après-midi aussi il n'y
a pas de vote les sénateurs défendent
leurs amendements ensuite la Commission
donne son avis le gouvernement aussi et
puis ensuite il ne se passe rien on
passe aux amendements suivants c'est
parce que nous sommes dans la procédure
du vote unique il n'y aura qu'un seul
vote sur l'ensemble du texte à la fin
des différentes prises de parole mais
les sénateurs qui ont vu leurs
amendements rejetés par le gouvernement
puisque le gouvernement n'en a retenu
que les sénateurs qui ont vu leurs
amendements rejetés ont tout de même le
droit de les défendre pendant deux
minutes et les sénateurs de gauche ont
choisi de prendre ce droit de le faire
valoir il multiplie donc les prises de
parole des prises de parole ponctuées
par le même texte ça a dû être difficile
de à vous l'échapper pardon le même
texte donc il commence à dire que on a
des vitalisé la fonction parlementaire
et il termine en disant on ne lâche rien
pourquoi parce que d'ici quelques
minutes d'ici quelques heures la
mobilisation va s'élancer dans la rue et
c'est une manière de galvaniser les
manifestants Quentin merci Audrey pour
toutes ces explications notamment autour
de l'article 44 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution ce vote bloqué qui fait
qu'il n'y a pas de vote sur les
amendements que le gouvernement n'a pas
retenu mais la gauche qui donc continue
de les défendre malgré tout pour en
parler j'accueil ici pierre ouzulia
bonjour bonjour
vous êtes sénateur communiste des
Hauts-de-Seine un mot sur effectivement
effectivement cette dévitalisation du
Parlement que dénonce la gauche le mec
qui maintient le fait de vouloir
défendre ses amendements même s'ils ne
pourront pas être dans le texte à la fin
vous voulez être là jusqu'au bout
défendre ses mesures oui alors la
démocratie fonctionne en mode dégradé il
y a plus de débats contradictoires on
nous répond pas on pose des questions de
fond qui ne sont pas débattus c'est
évidemment terriblement frustrant pour
un parlementaire parce que nous ce qui
nous intéresse surtout au Sénat c'est le
débat d'idée on l'a pu il y avait dans
tous les articles à venir des sujets
fondamentaux qui préoccupent les
Français et donc nous on continue malgré
tout afin de notre travail de
parlementaire parce qu'on veut ici au
Sénat exprimer porter la voix de tout
celles et tous ceux qui vont manifester
ou qui ne manifestons pas et qui sont
très soucieux de leur retraite et de ce
qui va leur arriver après le 44 aliné à
trois de la Constitution il est rarement
utilisé la dernière fois je crois que
c'était il y a il y a 10 ans
qu'est-ce que ça dit de ce qui se joue
autour de l'examen de cette réforme des
retraite tu auras un avant après parce
qu'on a eu toute l'utilisation des en
parlementaires du du Règlement du Sénat
la réunion de la commission pour
réécriture pour écrire le projet de loi
vous le dites sur Un avant-après cet
examen bien sûr alors à plusieurs titres
d'abord je pense que le gouvernement a
fait un acte d'autorité en choisissant
la procédure du du budget rectificatif
de la sécurité sociale parce que ça
limite la possibilité de déposer des
amendements et surtout sa limite le
temps le temps et donc on est tous
toujours au Sénat 20 jours à l'Assemblée
nationale exactement on est tous rivés
sur cette date limite du dimanche demain
soir à minuit or sur un texte aussi
important qui a un texte qui qui touche
à quelque chose de primordial qui est le
sens de la vie quel quel sens vous les
donner à votre vie et quel sens vous
voulez donner à votre travail il fallait
laisser à la représentation nationale le
temps de s'exprimer sur la longueur on
aurait passer trois mois sur un texte
parce que derrière ce qui est ce qui est
un enjeu fondamental c'est le projet de
société à quoi ça sert de travailler
pour qui comment c'est des questions que
se posent tous les Français les français
et notamment les jeunes et on le voit
bien les jeunes sont perte de sens par
rapport à leur vie par rapport à leur
travail je pense qu'on aurait pu choisir
le moment d'un débat parlementaire pour
évoquer toutes ces questions je vous
laisse vous faire réagir à ce qu'a dit
Audrey vue états le fait qu'il y a cette
mobilisation cette septième journée qui
va démarrer dans dans les rues de Paris
cet après-midi comment est-ce que cette
mobilisation monsieur ouzulia elle elle
échange elle communique avec ce qui se
joue dans dans le Sénat et inversement
vous connaissez la tradition de la
gauche donc les parlementaires ils sont
pas derrière la mobilisation sociale ils
sont pas devant non plus ils sont à côté
ils l'accompagne en parallèle exactement
avec une indépendance nous on a nos
façons de travailler les syndicalistes
les leurs mais on est là ensemble on les
accompagne est-ce que s'il y a un vote
de la réforme par la droite et le centre
d'ici demain soir ça peut démobiliser je
pense pas je pense pas parce que on voit
très bien que ce qu'il y a derrière la
contestation de la réforme de retraite
c'est quelque chose de beaucoup plus
large et vous le voyez notamment dans
les petites villes moyennes de la France
moi je suis d'origine corrézienne quand
vous avez 2000 personnes qui manifestent
à celle c'est pas uniquement pour les
retraites c'est pour pour dire une forme
de ras-le-bol général par rapport à ce
qui se passe en France et notamment dans
les territoires ruraux un dernier mot
qu'est-ce qui se joue dans l'hémicycle
on va vers un vote sur l'ensemble du
texte à quel moment selon vous peut-être
aujourd'hui mais plus certainement
demain midi
ça serait une défaite du président de la
République je pense parce qu'il se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec une majorité
très éthique étriquée qui est concentrée
uniquement dans le groupe des
Républicains du Sénat et je vois pas
comment on peut gouverner la France avec
comme majorité les républicains du Sénat
merci Pierre aux Olya pour je vous
analyse merci nous on retourne dans
l'hémicycle où c'est Michel meunier qui
a la parole de ses ambitions il est
facile d'invoquer l'inclusion à l'école
l'inclusion au travail il semble
beaucoup plus difficile à l'état de
doter l'éducation nationale d'auxiliaire
d'éducation formée et en nombre auprès
des enfants le recours aux aidants
familiaux dans un contexte d'inégalité
salariale entre les femmes et les hommes
n'est alors que la persistance d'un
modèle patriarcal où la charge du soin
est exercée par les femmes naturellement
compétentes et exigeant ni formation ni
accompagnement ni prise en charge
financière que simplement une maigre
compensation merci un amendement 399
madame varias
je suis le président je vais me
permettre de m'adresser à monsieur le
rapporteur Savary pour lui rappeler que
nous ne sommes pas dupe et que nous
n'avons jamais douté que l'huile n'était
pas Nupe
néanmoins les Français monsieur le
rapporteur mobilisés une fois encore
dans la rue aujourd'hui comme nous ne
sommes pas dupes et dans cette inutile
dans cette émission que nous sommes là
pour nous faire l'écho de leur colère
contre cette réforme que le gouvernement
veut nous imposer à marche forcée en
bâillonnant le Parlement et amusant pour
cela de toutes les procédures que lui
que lui accorde le règlement et la
Constitution nous ne lâcherons rien et
nous les lâcherons pas ceci étant dit
beaucoup d'amendements concerné les
demandes de rapport nous demandons ici
que le gouvernement remet un rapport
pour faire le bilan de l'application de
cet article si jamais il devait être
voté plus précisément nous souhaitons un
rapport sur l'extension de l'assurance
vieillesse pour les aidants tous les
parents d'enfants handicapés et non
seulement sont complément dans une
logique de simplification des démarches
et de l'accès aux soins en effet notre
pays compte plus de 8 millions de
projets dents apportant une aide
régulière et fréquente dans un cadre non
professionnel à une personne handicapée
une personne âgée dépendante j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour saluer le
travail précieux réalisé par mon
camarade pierre dareville député des
Blues du Rhône sur sa proposition de loi
pour une reconnaissance sociale des
aidants notre amendement va dans le sens
des ambitions de sa proposition de loi
de jeter les bases d'un statut pour les
prochaines dents à travers différentes
mesures visant à leur accorder des
droits effectifs une reconnaissance
sociale même s'il n'aura pas de suite
alors la vie de la commission sur le
rapporteur ils sont des demandes de
rapport sans avis défavorable mais
certaines vous demandent sont
satisfaites puisque nous allons prendre
en compte justement les possibilités de
prélèvement
de versement à la source des prestations
sociales donc l'automatisation des
prestations sociales ça rapporte qui va
être
accompli réalisé pardon par lamex par
Madame Raymonde ponce et moi-même donc
nous pourrons vous donner
aux fruits
suite à nos travaux
suite à nos travaux nous pouvons nous
pouvons vous donner des précisions quant
à ce dispositif
gouvernement
pour les mêmes raisons et j'ajoute que
pour ce qui concerne le non recours en
particulier un rapport parlementaire a
été rédigé à leur part madame Grangeon
qui était député avant d'être ministre à
mes côtés et par votre collègue Nathalie
voulait sénatrice c'est aussi un point
sur lequel les sénateurs peuvent
s'appuyer merci donc défavorable
donc l'amendement 4700 neuf monsieur
benaroche
qui est le président bonjour c'est un
amendement que porte le groupe sous
l'initiative de Mélanie vosgel mais là
il vous gèle d'ailleurs qui m'a laissé
un message en me disant que vous le
comprendriez donc je vais vous l'énoncer
vous avez décidé de dévitaliser la
fonction parlementaire par l'addition de
toutes les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laisserions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées nous ne sommes pas
dupe les Français non plus nous ne
lâcherons rien nous ne les lâcherons pas
je confirme le message de Mélanie Vogel
et je vous envoie le même
cet article là concerne le fait que
notre système de retraite ne tient pas
suffisamment compte du travail du Caire
mais se limite à la prise en compte du
travail salarial on connaît mon accent
anglais donc je vais préciser que c'est
de travailler du Caire une personne qui
prépare à manger pour d'autres une
personne qui s'occupe de ses paroles une
personne qui passe l'aspirateur pour que
d'autres n'aient pas à le faire c'est ça
en fait ce travail du Caire n’ouvre pas
de droit à la retraite au contraire en
fait vu que la personne qui va passer
une partie de sa journée à faire ce
travail a forcément moins de temps et
moins d'énergie disponible pour des
activités salariales
ce qui veut dire parfois qu'elle soit
contrainte de travailler à temps partiel
ou qu'elle cherche un poste qui lui
permettrait de jongler entre les
différentes tâches chacun d'entre vous
c'est ce que c'est certains d'entre vous
l'ont sûrement pratiqué et dans votre
famille vous en avez sûrement aussi
qu'il le faut heureusement d'ailleurs en
parallèle d'autres profitent du fait
qu'elle s'occupe du travail du Caire ils
en profitent de fait ce n'est pas une
volonté d'en profiter mais c'est ainsi
en fait quand il y a des personnes qui
gagnent plus et qui par conséquent
cotisent plus pour leur retraite grâce
au travail du Caire effectué par
d'autres il y a donc des personnes qui
ont une retraite plus élevée parce que
tout au long de leur vie ils ont pu
profiter de ce travail des autres il
faudrait alors augmenter la
reconnaissance du travail du cœur dans
les droits à la retraite une des
manières pour se faire serait par
exemple d'élargir l'affiliation à
l'assurance vieillesse des aidant qui
permettrait de valider des trimestres
alors la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur sur le moment que vient de
présenter monsieur benaroche
du gouvernement même chose un amendement
4710 monsieur Pernic merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre collègue
un amendement donc qui complète d'une
certaine façon de précédente parce que
même si l'affiliation à l'assurance
vieilles des aidants permet de valider
les trimestres les aidances ont tout de
même pernisé parce que leur aide a
également des répercussions sur leur
salaire par le biais d'une diminution du
revenu annuel moyen en effet si le
revenu reconnu pendant ces périodes est
considérablement inférieur il tire le
revenu annuel moyen vers le bas et
l'aidant se retrouvent avec moins de
droits à la retraite cet amendement vise
donc à demander au gouvernement un
rapport pour évaluer la possibilité
d'exclure ces années du calcul du
salaire annuel moyen et cela même si
vous avez décidé de dévitaliser la
fonction parlementaire par l'addition de
toutes les c'est dur que vous offre la
Constitution et les règlements vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droits de coalisées et bien non nous
ne sommes pas dupes les Français non
plus nous ne lâcherons rien nous les
lâcherons pas le travail du prendre soin
notre régime des retraites qui est
construit autour du travail salarial
n'en tient pas compte il pénalise un
site toutes les personnes qui ont font
de plus ils risquent de les rendre
financièrement dépendantes au moment de
leur retraite dépendante d'autres qui
eux n'ont pas effectué du travail du
Caire cette situation est doublement
injuste parce que non seulement ces
personnes se sont occupées d'autres
personnes qui en avaient besoin mais
sont pénalisés financièrement au moment
de leur départ à la retraite
merci alors la vie
de la commission monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président
défavorable un abonnement
3996 madame a poursaut poli de
notre amendement demande un rapport
pouvant déboucher sur une augmentation
de la durée maximale d'affiliation à
lassurance vieillesse pour les aidants
aidants afin de mieux tenir compte de la
réalité vécue cette proposition
s'inspire du travail de nos collègues du
groupe GDR de janvier 2018 et traduit
dans leur propositions de loi pour une
reconnaissance sociale des aidants les
associations des dents de signal les
critères d'affiliation à l'avats ont des
critères très stricts en effet seul un
membre de la famille peut bénéficier de
la majorité des trimestres et les dents
doit cesser totalement travailler
pendant une période de 30 mois
interrompus pour toucher les trimestres
majorés par ailleurs certains aidants ne
rentrent dans aucune case et ne
bénéficie d'aucune aide ainsi un aidant
dont le parent est malade du cancer ne
bénéficie ni d'un congé de procédant ni
de droit à la retraite avec votre
réforme le nombre des dents affil à
l'avant va donc passer de 60000 à 100
000 en comparaison au nombre des dents
dans notre pays estimé à plus de 9
millions nous avons à dispositif qui ne
va toucher que 1% des aidants nous
voulons élargir la durée maximale
d'affiliation à l'assurance vieillesse
pour les aidants à deux ans au lieu d'un
an actuellement et je vais terminer par
une petite répétition dans l'art dans la
mythologie grecque Sisyphe est condamné
à faire rouler un rocher en haut d'une
montagne jusqu'à la fin des temps
puisque ce rocher finit toujours par
redescendre il est obligé de répéter et
de reproduire cette même action alors
vous avez décidé de dévitaliser la
fonction parlementaire par l'addition de
toutes les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre des mots
clés nous ne sommes pas dupe les
Français non plus nous ne lâcherons rien
alors la vie de
la commission
c'est dommage c'est pas bien c'était
bien parti ça finit mal mais c'est un
sujet très important en ce qui concerne
cette affiliation à l'assurance
effectivement pour l'instant il y a une
avancée quand même sociale il faut la
noter bien sûr on peut toujours plus
évidemment on peut plus mais il y a déjà
quand même une avancée c'est la raison
pour laquelle la Commission a gardé le
scatsuko 4 trimestres qui sont pris
c'est mieux qu'avant il y avait rien il
y a quatre effectivement nous avons été
aussi sollicité par différentes
associations par le mouvement des
personnes handicapées etc bon 8
trimestres on s'est posé la question
Elizabeth Doisneau et moi-même et de
même que l'avat étonnée pour un seul
membre de la famille on se posait la
question aussi pour les demandes de la
famille mais là on est arrivé à un
dispositif plus important qui mérite
mais derrière il y a un coût et le but
aussi de cette réforme c'est d'essayer
de gommer certaines inégalités mais on
peut pas gommer toutes les inégalités
non plus et le but également c'est de
faire en sorte que on arrive à combler
les déficits de notre Assurance Retraite
donc on peut pas non plus troubler
creuser le chemin était 3 chemin de la
solidarité bien entendu mais ce qui nous
importe c'est pas perte de vue qu'il
faut faire en sorte que cet effort
collectif soit réparti le plus
globalement possible c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous n'avons pas donné
suite à cette réflexion mais qui est
tout à fait importante merci
Monsieur le
monsieur le ministre de ma vie
exactement pour les mêmes raisons que
celle d'évoquer
Audrey vous êtes toujours avec moi
depuis la tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle on arrive progressivement à
l'article 13 qui est la prochaine étape
pour les sénateurs il y a quoi dans
l'article 13 Audrey et bien l'article 13
c'est un article important là aussi
puisqu'il vise à faciliter le cumul
emploi retraite et il parlera aussi des
questions de la retraite progressive
vous savez des thèmes majeurs donc dans
ce texte il faudra aussi surveiller la
suite de cet article 13 dans les
articles additionnels pourquoi parce
qu'il y a à l'intérieur un amendement
porté par le président des républicains
Bruno Retailleau qui vise à accélérer la
fin des régimes spéciaux d'ici 2040 un
amendement qui n'a pas été retenu dans
le vote final par le gouvernement il
faudra donc voir si la droite décide de
le soutenir pendant deux minutes aussi
elle le RET ire si elle le retire ça va
faire tomber des dizaines d'amendements
de la gauche qui lui sont reliés ça
devrait accélérer donc drastiquement les
débats à voir donc si cet amendement est
défendu ou non voilà c'est l'enjeu un
peu des prochaines heures après cet
article 13 mais pour l'heure et bien on
est toujours sur des prises de parole
concernant les aidants de personnes
handicapées retournant l'hémicycle
alors nous allons passer nous en avons
terminé avec l'article 12 et après
l'article 12 à l'avancement 26 et 86
rectifiés monsieur fialer Adam monsieur
Dagbert
non non
il y a pas de souci merci merci Monsieur
Je présente monsieur mis spécial
collègue les saisonniers sont essentiels
pour l'économie touristique mais
également pour d'autres secteurs comme
l'agriculture afin de répondre aux
besoins de main d'oeuvre qui fluctue
énormément sur une année complète la
situation de ces travailleurs qui
connaissent la précarité inhérente à des
professions rythmées par les saisons est
loin d'être satisfaisante quand en
termes de salaire que de conditions de
travail la réforme de retraite préoccupe
également ses salariés et à juste titre
aussi notre amendement demande un
rapport pour mesurer l'impact du présent
projet de loi sur les pensions de
retraite des saisonniers et sur la
possibilité de mieux les protéger en
leur accordant comme pour à d'autres le
droit à validation de trimestre
supplémentaire lors des périodes non
travaillées je vous remercie
merci la vie
la vie de la commission monsieur
quand vous travaillez pas je veux bien
mais où va-t-on quoi bon c'est pas c'est
une réforme c'est un système pas
répartition c'est un système contributif
quoi où sont les cotisations qui donnent
des droits faut quand même quelque part
respecter un peu l'ossature de notre
dispositif parce que à force de détruire
de le l'aménageur va finir par le
détruire donc je tire votre attention
dans ce type d'amendement qui n'amène me
semble-t-il aucune valeur ajoutée par
rapport à la réflexion comme c'est un
rapport en plus avis défavorable ce
ministre
ça naviguait favorable par un principe
si je puis dire puisque nous ne prenons
pas les demandes de rapport même si le
corps travaille aussi sur la question
des saisonniers
bien double avis défavorable nous allons
nous avons avant le titre 3 un
amendement 33,98 que Monsieur salmon
présente il porte sur le titre
merci monsieur le Président par cet
amendement nous souhaitons dénoncer les
mesures insuffisantes pour faciliter les
transitions entre emploi et retraite
d'après l'adresse à la fin de l'année
2020 le dispositif de retraite
progressive concernait 24000 personnes
ce qui reste vous le reconnaîtrez très
peu
le corps a rappelé dans son dernier
rapport annuel que si des progrès ont
été réalisés ces dernières années en
matière d'emploi des seniors la question
des transitions vers la retraite reste
plaignante car une proportion sensible
des assurés passe par des périodes de
chômage ou d'inactivité entre leur
sortie définitive du marché du travail
et leur départ à la retraite par rapport
au nombre de personnes en situation de
cumul emploi retraite le dispositif de
retraite progressif reste selon les
termes de l'adresse très très marginal
pourtant les bénéfices de la retraite
progressive pour la santé sont nombreux
puisque des chercheurs notent entre
autres une réduction de la fatigue et du
stress source de risque psychosociaux
par exemple il semblerait juste et
participant à l'attractivité du
dispositif que les bénéficiaires de la
retraite progressive puissent bénéficier
de leurs droits à la retraite sur la
base d'un temps plein par exemple aussi
vous pourriez décider de retirer cette
réforme qui va nous le savons prolonger
le de précarité maintenant des milliers
de personnes supplémentaires sans emploi
ni retraite l'adresse révélait en 2020
que le taux de pauvreté des personnes ni
en emploi ni en retraite de 53 à 69 ans
était de 32%. et cela monsieur le
ministre que vous signifiez par
faciliter les transitions entre emploi
et retraite faciliter pour qui pas pour
les cases populaires pas pour les plus
vulnérables et je ne voudrais pas que
l'on oublie que vous avez décidé de
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
qui vous offrent que vous offre la
Constitution à le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
les retraites des Français entre vos
mains entre les mains des droites
coalisées nous ne sommes pas dupe de vos
manœuvres les Français non plus nous ne
lâcherons rien nous ne les lâcherons pas
merci alors la vie de monsieur le
rapporteur oh c'est la vie de la
commission des favorables
du gouvernement défavorable
et nous passons maintenant à l'article
13 mes chers collègues je suis saisi
d'une demande de parole pour le groupe
socialiste madame Annie le héros
merci monsieur le Président alors cet
article 13 concerne deux dispositifs
principaux la création de droits à
pension en cumulant un emploi et la
retraite et étendre la retraite
progressive à la fonction publique en
général et aux indépendants alors nous
retrouvons regrettable de ne pouvoir
échanger sur ces deux outils nouveaux
puisque vous avez décidé de dévitaliser
la fonction parlementaire par l'addition
de toutes les procédures que vous offre
la constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées nous ne sommes pas
dupes les Français n'ont plus nous ne
lâcherons rien nous ne les lâcherons pas
pour revenir à cet article 13 la
libéralisation du dispositif cumule
emploi retraite vise à faire travailler
les retraités en raison du montant
insuffisant de leur tension de retraite
pour mettre un peu de dans les épinards
de ceux et celles qui ont travaillé dur
et qui n'en peuvent déjà plus le cumul
emploi retraite est inégalitaire seuls
sont concernés les personnes qui
disposent de qualifications reconnus de
durant leur carrière et qui partent en
bonne santé et avec des pensions déjà
correctes et qui peuvent reprendre
facilement une activité plutôt que de
corriger les inégalités de carrière et
notamment l'égalité salariale entre les
femmes et les hommes cet article risque
de fragiliser encore davantage la santé
des personnes qui vont devoir poursuivre
une activité salariée au-delà de 64 ans
avec vos deux années de travail
obligatoire les personnes qui auront des
carrières pénibles ne pourront plus
travailler comme vous le leur demandez
dans les IAD et Côtes-d'Armor que
pensent les ouvriers les ouvrières que
pensent les aides à domicile sur le
dispositif de cumul en point retraite
alors qu'ils sont déjà cassés à 45 ans
je peux vous dire qu'il n'aspire pas à
un cumul en poids retraite ils
attendaient avec attend impatience de
partir à 62 ans et ils devront attendre
deux années pour y prétendre
hier sont souvent des femmes et elles
demandent une revalorisation salariale
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Jérémy pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre l'article 13 du projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale à
rectificative aurait mérité un véritable
débat et nous ne pouvons que regretter
de ne pouvoir affronter nos arguments
sur cette disposition en effet l'article
13 prévoit deux mesures au philosophie
opposés d'un côté il favorise et
améliore le recours à la retraite pour
qui permet de partir à 60 ans aux
travailleurs une transition vers la
retraite en réduisant son temps de
travail sans perte de salaire ni perte
de droit à l’impression de retraite ce
mécanisme qui permet une transition des
seniors vers la retraite doit être
encouragé nous regrettons la complexité
des démarches pour en bénéficier et le
choix des employeurs de préférer souvent
les ruptures conventionnelles à ce
dispositif de maintien dans l'emploi des
seniors ainsi en 2020 seul 23 800 des
salariés bénéficier d'une retraite
progressive de notre côté cet article 13
ouvre des droits pour les retraités qui
décideraient de reprendre le travail en
ayant recours au cumul emploi retraite
sur cette disposition il aurait fallu un
débat sur la conception de la société
que nous voulons voulons nous une
société où nos aciers accomplissent des
petits boulots pour compléter leur
pension de retraite insuffisante ou
voulons-nous d'une société où les
travailleuses et les travailleurs
financés par les cotisations sociales à
l'assurance vie illes pourrait avoir une
pension digne jusqu'à la fin de leur
jour si les entreprises rémunérées
correctement les salariés si les femmes
étaient payées à compétences et à poste
équivalent aux hommes au même niveau les
retraités ne seraient pas obligés de
devoir travailler ainsi il faut bien
avoir en tête qu'il ne s'agit pas de
retraités qui souhaitent reprendre une
activité professionnelle mais bel et
bien de retraités qui n'ont pas d'autres
choix financièrement je vous remercie
qui Monsieur Daniel Breuillet
merci monsieur le Président la retraite
progressive est en effet un dispositif
qui pourrait être efficace pour
faciliter la transition vers la retraite
surtout pour les emplois les plus
difficiles même si nous jugeons que le
gouvernement ne va pas assez loin pour
démocratiser améliorer ce dispositif qui
est loin d'être parfait en effet les
retraités ne s'en saisissent pas assez
seulement 2% d'entre eux et bien que cet
article vise à changer la donne en
ouvrant ce dispositif au fonctionnaire
et en imposant aux employeurs de
justifier leur refus quand un salarié en
fait la demande nous proposons pour
notre part de rendre impossible pour
l'employeur de refuser une telle demande
et
ça devrait devenir donc un véritable
droit le problème avec ce dispositif
c'est qu'il aurait fallu maintenir cette
possibilité de départ en trait de
progressive à 60 ans voire même plutôt
pour les carrières longues mais nous ne
partageons pas la philosophie d'ouvrir
la question du cumul emploi retraite qui
visent finalement à considérer que la
vie n'est faite que pour travailler et
que les retraités pauvres auront comme
ça la possibilité de rajouter de mettre
un peu de beurre dans les épinards que
le montant de leur retraite ne permet
pas alors bien que la retraite
progressive soit un élément très utile
pour faciliter la transition vers la
traite nous ne pouvons nous résoudre à
voter un dispositif mais heureusement
nous n'aurons pas le voté puisque vous
avez choisi d'utiliser tous les moyens
que vous donne la Constitution pour
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
possibles 47 ans 44 38 article 42 vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées ce ne sera pas le
cas et même si on ne peut plus débattre
même si nous amendements ne seront pas
votés nous pouvons toujours et je vous
en remercie monsieur le Président de
l'avoir souligné retirer nos amendements
et je signale au gouvernement qu'il a
aussi le droit de retirer son projet de
retraite
à l'examen de deux amendements
identiques de suppression de l'article
l'amendement
3381 madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors les
réformes des retraites s'enchaînent
toujours avec le même but productiviste
travailler plus pour gagner des points
de PIB et ces points petits points de
PIB reposent sur les travailleurs et il
repose par l'augmentation là oui sans
fin de leur temps de travail dans la
poursuite de cette logique sans fin nous
discutons donc d'un article qui vise à
favoriser le cumul en poireaux retraite
pour que même en retraite on travaille
et on produise encore et encore l'objet
de et je dirais c'est souvent parce que
les gens ils recourt parce que souvent à
cause de la baisse tendancielle du
niveau relatif des pensions l'objet de
l'amendement n'est pas de remettre en
question bien sûr le cumul emploi
retraite c'est un choix ou un droit ce
dont il s'agit c'est d'interroger la
logique sans fond et la poursuite d'une
logique effectivement qui fonce vers le
mur climatique sans aucun questionnement
sur le modèle de production et bien non
l'urgence n'est pas de travailler plus
mais de pouvoir d'avoir le droit de
partir dès 60 ans pour profiter d'année
de repos en bonne santé
cette réforme ce targue de créer 300 000
emplois enfin vainc que créer 300 000
emplois par cette prolongement de deux
ans alors qu'il va aussi produire 200
000 seniors qui vont rester dans le sas
de précarité j'aurais bien aimé
développé mais je reçois j'ai reçu un
instant un message de Joël Labbé qui me
demande de de vous lire un message
alors ce message c'est vous avez décidé
de dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement vous espériez sans doute que
nous laissions la retraite des Français
entre les mains des droits de coalisés
nous ne sommes pas dupe les Français non
plus nous ne lâcherons rien nous ne les
lâcherons pas c'était le message pour
conclure
un amendement 4002 rectifier madame
gréaume merci monsieur le président
cet article 13 prévoit la libéralisation
du dispositif d'emploi retraite qui vise
à faire travailler les retraités en
raison du montant insuffisant de leur
pension de retraite cette mesure a été
déjà présente dans la réforme des
retraites 2019 qui prévoyaient de rendre
le cumul emploi retraite plus avantageux
financièrement et prévoyez d'accorder
des points supplémentaires pour leur
pension ici l'article 13 prévoit la
constitution des droits à pension en
cumulant retraite qui s'en trouverait
plus élevé la philosophie de cet article
13 converge avec celle du projet de loi
du gouvernement qui consiste à faire
travailler tout le monde plus longtemps
y compris à partir du moment où les
personnes liquides leur droit à la
retraite notre conception de la société
est à l'opposé nous souhaitons la
retraite pour profiter de la vie sociale
familiale culturelle et sportive pour
s'émanciper bénéficier du droit au repos
et au temps libre le monsieur le
ministre j'en profite pour vous dire que
je trouve scandaleux la LED du 9 mars du
président de la République au syndicat
refuse en donc de les recevoir
scandaleux de dire que nous débattons
tous les dans cette hémicycle c'est faux
votre loi est injuste et injustifiée le
recours aux procédures pour bloquer nos
amendements rendre ce texte illégitime
et quel que soit l'issue de l'examen de
ce texte la bataille pour son retrait se
poursuivra je vous le dis nous ne
lâcherons pas et nous continuerons à
soutenir le peuple qui est dans la rue
et qui manifeste pour son retrait et
nous sommes nombreux merci
alors l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur merci monsieur le
Président mais quel dommage quel dommage
de vouloir supprimer ces dispositifs de
transition on essaie tous mis dans la
réflexion qui nous anime d'accord pour
dire qu'il y avait une zone une période
de transition entre la fin de la vie
active et des vue de la vie sédentaire
et qu'il était important que la société
voit ça différemment à travers divers
dispositifs dont la retraite progressive
et donc cumul emploi retraite
pourquoi voulez-vous que les personnes
qui ont un revenu faible qui sont en
retraite ne puissent pas si elles ont
envie retravailler pourquoi voulez-vous
que des personnes qui font le choix de
retravailler parce que l'inactivité ne
leur convient pas forcément pourquoi
voulez-vous les priver et puis une chose
importante à rappeler d'antiplositive
cumul emploi retraite c'est que qui doit
nous faire réfléchir par rapport aux
dispositifs de retraite anticipée pour
carrière longue 20% de ces personnes qui
bénéficient d'une carrière anticipée
retourne en cumulent emploi retraite
après ça doit quelque part nous
interpeller en ce qui concerne la
retraite progressive c'est une avancée
qui est proposée puisqu'il est il est
proposé à travers cette article 13 de
l'étendre
en plus des salariés du privé au
fonctionnaires et aux différentes
professions notamment les professions
libérales l’étendre à tous donc c'est
une avancée tout à fait significative
mais nous pensons que dans le cas de
cette réflexion de la transition entre
la partie active et la partie sédentaire
de notre vie il est peut-être important
de pouvoir laisser ce dispositif de
retraite progressif dès ce voient 100
ans c'est là que nous avons actuellement
une divergence avec le gouvernement
monsieur le ministre puisque peut-être
que il serait intéressant de l'aménager
des 60 ans avec une quantité de travail
effectivement de 80% pour que ce soit
progressif que là aussi ça ne soit pas
un coup
prohibitif peut-être que nous pouvons
dans ce cadre-là si vous en étiez
d'accord monsieur le ministre aménagé
encore pour que il y ait effectivement
une prise de décision partagée entre le
l'employeur pour faire en sorte qu'on
arrive à laisser au droit actuel le
départ à 60 ans qui serait effectivement
élargi à l'ensemble du public et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je comprends
votre inquiétude notamment par rapport à
l'élargissement aux fonctionnaires qui
peut être une voix qui si elle était
trop empruntée pourrait mettre en
difficulté également le fonctionnement
de certaines administrations donc votre
inquiétude me paraît tout à fait
légitime et il s'agit de doser pour que
ce soit un objet de transition qui amène
une valeur ajoutée dans cette période de
vie merci le ministre
merci monsieur le Président la ville de
du gouvernement et évidemment
défavorable sur les amendements de
suppression d'abord nous pensons que le
fait de faciliter l'accès à la retraite
progressive est un progrès le fait de
l'ouvrir aux agents de la fonction
publique et aussi un progrès et une
réponse et une attente exprimée de
depuis longtemps et que ça facilite
finalement la possibilité de lever le
pied si mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs me permettent cette expression
avant de partir à la retraite pour ce
qui concerne le cumulant retraite
permettez-moi une remarque pour dire que
évidemment il a des retraités qui vont
faire le choix de cumuler leur retraite
avec un emploi et d'autres qui dans la
situation qu'ils connaissent n'auront
pas le choix mais mais feront
à travailler pour compléter leurs
revenus c'est d'ailleurs
une manière pour moi de dire que ça ne
concerne pas que les retraités qui ont
des qualifications que les retraités qui
ont des compétences particulières
puisque malheureusement vous le dites
madame Libin il y a des retraités qui
ont des petites retraites et qui doivent
cumuler cette retraite avec des
activités qui ne sont pas nécessairement
des activités très qualifiées on a
peut-être tous en tête celles et ceux
qui livrent tel ou tel prospectus ou
font des activités de services ou de
complément qui permettront d'être
contributive on peut considérer que la
situation initiale et la cause de cela
n'est pas satisfaisante c'est le cas
mais ça ne doit pas nous empêcher je
crois d'apporter un droit à ceux qui par
choix ou par contrainte on accumulé un
emploi avec leur retraite la remarque
que je voulais faire sur ce point-là
monsieur le Président concerne peut-être
la précision à apporter sur le fait que
ce que nous vous proposons par la loi
concerne le caractère contributif du
cumulon plein retraite dans le cas du
régime général la loi ne peut se
substituer aux partenaires sociaux pour
faire en sorte que ce cumuler l'emploi
retraite devienne contributif pour les
régimes complémentaires mais sans
préjugés des décisions des partenaires
sociaux et sont évidemment me substituer
à leur responsabilité je pense que c'est
un mouvement que nous initions et qui
serait bienvenu que les régimes
complémentaires alignent aussi leur
règle en matière de capacité
contributive des
du cumul en plein retraite enfin
monsieur le rapporteur a évoqué la
l'ouverture de la retraite progressive à
60 ans plutôt que 62 plutôt plus
exactement quatre ans avant l'âge
d'ouverture des droits plutôt que deux
ans si nous le disons comme cela en
élargissant la disposition proposée par
le gouvernement le coût de 400 millions
d'euros par an si nous le disons comme
monsieur le rapporteur l'a écrit en
restaignant cette possibilité au
maintien d'une activité professionnelle
à 80% nous sommes entre 130 150 millions
d'euros par an et si nous travaillons
sur les règles d'ici la CMP sur les
règles d'autorisation pour revenir aux
règles actuelles si je puis dire et ne
pas appliquer à cette période entre n-4
et -2 des règles avec nécessité de faire
la preuve d'une incompatibilité avec le
fonctionnement d'entreprise on doit
certainement pouvoir trouver quelques
quelques marches si je puis dire et
recalibrer ce dispositif gageons que les
discussions d'ici la CMP permettent
d'avancer
merci nous allons examiné un amendement
qui vise à faciliter les transitions
entre emploi et retraite j'accueille ici
Sylvie vermillet bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice centriste du Jura faudra bien
parler dans votre micro s'il vous plaît
on a vu que un de vos amendements avait
fait consensus aujourd'hui cela concerne
les élus les maires et en quelques mots
qu'est-ce que votre amendement qui va
donc faire partie du vote bloqué à la
fin qu'est-ce que ça va apporter de
nouveau il rend justice à la fonction
des lieux locales notamment des élus des
petites communes mon amendement il
concerne facilement 80% des élus des
territoires ruraux en tout cas des
petites communes tout simplement en
matière de retraite les élus qui
aujourd'hui perçoivent moins de 1833
euros par mois c'est-à-dire la moitié du
placement de la sécurité sociale tous
les élus qui perçoivent moins de cette
somme par mois en indemnité ne cotise
pas au régime de base il ne cotise qu'à
un régime complémentaire qui s'appelle
l'ircantheque et une cotise pas au
régime de base et mon amendement va leur
permettre sur option s'il le souhaite de
compléter leurs droits à la retraite on
a de plus en plus de mer qui pour
exercer leur fonction de maire réduisent
leur temps de travail se mettent à temps
partiel et quand ils font ça ils perdent
des droits à la retraite donc là les
mères qui le souhaitent seulement
pouvoir cotiser et avoir des droits
complets c'est pas un avantage
supplémentaire c'est le rétablissement
de droit vous aviez travaillé sur cette
mesure avec le ministre du socle pour
faire en sorte qu'elle soit bien écrite
et qu'elle puisse s'insérer dans le
texte absolument ça fait cinq ans que je
porte cette mesure j'essaye de faire en
sorte qu'on entend cette injustice ce
manque ce trou dans la raquette qu'il y
avait sur le le statut des élus et des
petites communes si je comprends bien
c'est vraiment les petites indemnités et
donc forcément les petites communes et
Olivier du soft a été sensible à cette
cause et a compris tout de suite que il
y avait une injustice et il a accepté
qu'on travaille ensemble sinon j'aurais
été sous le coup d'un article 40 donc on
a travaillé conjointement j'en suis
vraiment heureuse on voit ces débat
maintenant sur la transition entre
emplois et retraite vous avez été
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des finances vous avez écouté à
l'instant le ministre du soft qu'est-ce
que ça vous évoquait son discours
le cumul emploi retraite c'est quelque
chose maintenant qui va être générateur
de droit donc c'est une avancée et c'est
très bien même s'il y aura encore un
certain nombre de choses à régler
notamment pour tous les travailleurs
indépendants ou les systèmes de
cotisation qui sont quand même assez
particulier et puis sur la retraite
progressive il y a une volonté du
rapporteur
sur le fond René Paul Savary de l'ouvrir
cette retraite progressive dès 60 ans
avec le ministre
quant à lui expose que il y a un coût
qui devrait vraiment très important et
par contre il y aurait simplement une
mesure qui serait sans doute acceptable
c'est le fait d'ouvrir ce cumul emploi
retraite des 60 ans effectivement mais
en imaginant que les gens se mettent à
80% du temps de travail et pas à 50 50
ça ferait beaucoup à compenser 80% c'est
quelque chose d'envisageable donc
j'imagine qu'il y a un terrain d'entente
à trouver et bien on va voir dans les
prochains jours puisque le ministre a
évoqué effectivement les discussions
jusqu'à la CMP donc la Commission
mixparitaire en cette député cette
sénateur qui se réuniront mercredi un
dernier mot si vous le voulez bien sur
ces prises de parole de la gauche
sénatoriale qui dénonce la
dévitalisation du débat qu'est-ce que
toutes ces prises de parole à répétition
ça vous évoque où
je suis là depuis le début
début ça fait 10 jours que je suis là
jour et nuit jour et nuit je ne
comprends pas l'utilité de déposer 500
fois le même amendement je pense que au
Sénat on en a fait la preuve tout le
temps à chaque fois le débat il est
toujours possible et d'ailleurs on a eu
des moments de débat intéressant je
pense au débat sur le droit des femmes
avec notamment Laurence Rossignol où on
a su se retrouver sur des causes
communes pour les femmes qui ont au
moins un enfant il y a pas besoin de
disposer 500 fois le même amendement
donc moi je fais partie des gens qui
disent qu'à un moment donné ça suffit et
on peut toujours accepter je suis
toujours favorable au débat et la
discussion
500 fois le même amendement c'est pas
raisonnable et ça ressemble pas au Sénat
merci merci pour ces explications nous
retrouvons dans les musiques pour
écouter les débats
et injuste merci
le moment 4005 ben la barillas merci
monsieur le Président nous souhaitons la
suppression de l'alinéa 6 de l'article
13 pour les mêmes raisons que nous
demandons la suppression de l'article le
cumul emploi retraite est un dispositif
inégalitaire car il s'adresse
essentiellement aux personnes qui
dispose de qualifications reconnues
durant leur carrière qui partent en
bonne santé avec des pensions correctes
et à qui ce titre peuvent reprendre plus
facile et à ce qui à ce titre peuvent
reprendre plus facilement une activité
selon l'Insee les bénéficiaires actuels
du système du cumul emploi retraite sont
ainsi majoritairement des personnes qui
ont des carrières complètes ou des
niveaux de pension supérieurs à la
moyenne plutôt que de corriger les
inégalités de carrière qui concerne
particulièrement les femmes cet article
risque de fragiliser encore davantage
les personnes qui vont devoir poursuivre
une activité salariée au-delà de 64 ans
celles et ceux qui ont recours au cumul
emploi retraite sont les mêmes que
celles et ceux qui travaillent au-delà
62 ans pour bénéficier de la sur ce sont
les salariés dans la rémunération ne
permet pas de retraite digne et doivent
trouver des solutions pour avoir une
pension suffisante pour faire face à la
hausse des prix du quotidien et des
coûts des soins non remboursés par la
Sécurité sociale alors voilà encore un
amendement qui ne pourra avoir de suite
puisque vous avez décidé de dévitaliser
la fonction parlementaire par l'addition
de toutes les procédures que vous offre
la constitution et le règlement vous
expiriez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées nous ne sommes pas
dupe les Français non plus nous ne
lâcherons rien oui et nous ne les
la alors avis de la commission
et merci monsieur le Président quelques
minutes sur la vie il sera global à la
fois pour ses amendements de suppression
qui demandent la modification de
l'intitulé donc c'est pas d'une grande
utilité me semble-t-il donc ce sera un
avis bien sûr défavorable et puis les
suivants également qui demandent de
supprimer le aussi le calmer l'emploi
retraite moi je vous comprends pas là il
y a quelque chose qui va pas vous parler
des petites retraites vous êtes les
défenseurs de ceux qui ont des petites
retraites alors pourquoi voulez-vous
priver ces gens-là du cumul emploi
retraite c'est pour ceux qui l'ont
actuellement ça va ouvrir des droits ils
pourront reliquider derrière leur
retraite et améliorer plus tard leur
retraite
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que ça
peut rendre service à ces personnes
voilà premièrement
ceux qui sont actuellement en emploi
retraite pour en bénéficier deuxièmement
ce qui concerne les petites retraites
mais ça nous interpelle mes chers
collègues c'est pour ça qu'on propose
une réforme je vous rappelle je vous
rappelle quand même s'il vous plaît je
vous rappelle que le niveau moyen des
retraités actuellement en France c'est
103% par rapport au niveau des du
salaire moyen et que les prévisions du
corps dont vous parlez tant dont vous
faites des interprétations conduisent
toutes conduisent toutes à une baisse de
la pension moyenne dans les années qui
viennent ce sera
85%, ce sera plus en 3% c'est pour ça
qu'il faut réformer ce système et quelle
est la mesure qui permet de faire en
sorte que de façon moyenne on est une
meilleure retraite mais c'est la borne
d'âge parce qu'on sait bien que
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
conduit à un niveau moyen de retraite
qui n'est pas en augmentant par contre
c'est l'abordonnage qui fait qu'il y a
un meilleur revenu c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous vous c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes particulièrement
106 à ce niveau de retraite et que le
seul moyen de faire en sorte que cette
retraite qui dure de plus en plus
longtemps ne soit pas une retraite de
pauvres c'est de prendre des mesures
qu'on propose merci la vie la vie du
gouvernement
la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président la
vie des favorable sur les amendements de
suppression comme il sera défavorable
sur les amendements suivants qui
suppriment une partie de cet article à
l'exception bien sûr du 21 67 il n'a pas
encore été présenté mais qui est
rédactionnel je précise pour la bonne
information de tout ce que le cumul
emploi retraite sera contributif avec un
caractère légèrement rétroactif puisque
nous intégrerons dans ce caractère
contributif les activités exercées si la
loi est adoptée bien sûr à compter du
1er janvier 2023 donc de toute l'année
2023 monsieur le Président Gontard
vouliez faire un rappel au règlement je
crois qu'il faut respecter le principe
du rappel de règlement mais je vous
donne la parole allez oui merci merci
monsieur le Président effectivement le
principe du rappel au Règlement sur sur
le champ qui est accordé sur le champ je
suis d'accord et sur la l'article 44 bis
et sur la sincérité des débats
je vois et d'ailleurs je voudrais
remercier le rapporteur parce qu'on voit
toute sa frustration
sa grande frustration aujourd'hui et
depuis hier parce que il a envie du
débat il a envie de débattre il a envie
d'exprimer ses arguments et on voit
d'ailleurs toute la beauté dans cette
émission quand il y a ce débat mais
hélas vous en avez décidé autrement
ensemble avec le gouvernement vous avez
décidé ce 44-3 et donc ce débat ne peut
pas avoir lieu
ces regrettable c'est très embêtant mais
donc je vous demanderai et je vous
demanderai personnellement de à la fois
de ne pas à nous poser de questions
puisque nous ne pouvons pas répondre
vous a décidé qu'il n'y aurait pas de
débat donc faites en sorte que le débat
n'est pas lieu merci alors quatre
amendements qui vont faire l'objet d'une
discussion commune l'amendement 4010
monsieur lelec
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
mes chers collègues
en vérité je vous le dis
je vous le redis vous avez décidé de
dire stériliser la fonction
parlementaire par l'adhésion le par
l'addition de toutes les procédures dont
vous disposez
vous espériez sans doute que nous
laissions les retraites entre vos mains
nous ne sommes pas dupes les Français
non plus nous ne la ferons rien nous ne
lâcherons absolument rien
alors
c'est amendement vise au fond à remettre
en cause les alinéens 18 à 39
en effet le gouvernement propose de
modifier le dispositif à l'emploi
retraite en permettant l'acquisition de
nouveaux droits à la retraite lorsque le
cumul est réalisé après le départ à taux
plein et après liquidation de toutes les
pensions
cette mesure peut apparaître comme une
bonne chose monsieur le rapporteur en
ouvrant des droits pour celles et ceux
qui reprennent une activité
professionnelle
[Applaudissements]
merci
et l'amendement 44
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur vous nous avez
beau poser beaucoup de questions elles
sont elles sont intéressantes et on
aurait aimé que on puisse disposer
justement des changes plus fournis pour
avoir un dialogue plus plus au fond ce
que ce que je tenais à vous dire
Monsieur monsieur le rapporteur c'est
deux choses la première c'est que nous
sommes absolument pas contre les
dispositifs de transition bien au
contraire le problème est ce que nous
dénonçons c'est les systèmes subis le
temps partiel subit comme le cumulon
point retraite suit et c'est ça le
problème et vous le savez bien et vous
nous dites que votre retraite votre
réforme pardon va mieux organiser le
système de retraite et va fermer et va
permettre des retraites plus complètes
mais dans ces cas là votre votre système
de transition risque d'être frappé
d'une quasi obsolescence puisque plus
les retraites seront complètes moins les
gens auront besoin de cumuler avec leur
emploi donc ce que vous nous proposez
finalement c'est une finalité c'est à
dire c'est vers l'extinction du
dispositif de de cumulon retraite
merci ce que ce que je voudrais vous
mettre en garde c'est le système
américain le système américain vous avez
quasiment 30% des retraités qui dans les
cinq premières années continuent une
activité pourquoi c'est pas pour le
plaisir il s'agit pas d'un problème de
liberté c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens de continuer à vivre avec leur
simple leur simple retraite et ça c'est
un modèle de société que nous ne voulons
pas merci monsieur le Président alors un
abonnement ensuite
4000 16
madame Lindemann
oui chers collègues oui oui vous avez
décidé de dévitaliser la fonction
parlementaire par l'addition de toutes
les procédures que vous offre la
Constitution elle est le règlement je
vais les rappeler
47 ans article 38 du Règlement
44,3 et si j'écoute le président de la
République qui ne veut pas recevoir les
syndicats ce qui est quand même
l'ensemble des syndicats quel mépris il
peut avoir en leur direction mais qui en
plus
nous donne des grandes leçons sur il
faudra aller au terme de la démarche
parlementaire en excluant aucune des
mesures constitutionnelles dont
suspendre d'un instant à l'autre pour la
pose déjeuner vous suivez ces débats
pour la 10e journée consécutive autour
de la réforme des retraites depuis 9h30
sur l'antenne de Public Sénat on va
faire le bilan de cette matinée
d'échange avec Audrey wettaz en tribune
de presse de l'hémicycle Audrey que dire
de cette matinée et bien content on
plutôt vite on a étudié l'article 10 le
11 le 12 nous en sommes au 13 sur les 20
que compte le texte alors vous le savez
les sénateurs de gauche n'ont pas vu
leurs amendements retenus dans le vote
final du gouvernement miso de ils ont
quand même deux minutes pour défendre
leurs âmesment deux minutes qu'ils
prennent et pour marquer le coup face à
cette situation exceptionnelle pour
donner du rythme nous ont-ils dit ils
ont décidé de déployer tout sous
l'entendez peut-être derrière moi les
mêmes éléments de langage à chacune de
leurs prises de parole je vous propose
d'en écouter un extrait vous avez décidé
de dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous offre la constitution et le
règlement vous espériez sans doute que
nous laissions la retraite des Français
entre les mains des droites coalisées
nous sommes pas dupe et les Français
n'ont plus vous ne lâcherons rien nous
ne les lâcherons pas vous avez décidé de
dévitaliser la fonction parlementaire
par l'addition de toutes les procédures
que vous off de la Constitution et le
règlement vous espériez
il y a des retraites et les retraites
des Français entre les seuls mains vont
seulement des droits de coalisées mais
nous ne sommes pas dupe et les Français
non plus nous ne lâcherons rien nous ne
les lâcherons pas
ça fait des heures que ça dure vous
l'imaginez ça commence à agacer un petit
peu à droite je voulais revenir sur les
mots de fin de ces éléments de langage
nous ne lâcherons rien évidemment ils
ont en tête la mobilisation la
manifestation qui va s'élancer et dans
quelques minutes c'est une manière de
maintenir la pression et de galvaniser
les manifestants et puis petit point
agenda il faudra surveiller les articles
après l'article 13 puisqu'à l'intérieur
il y a un amendement du président les
républicains Bruno Retailleau qui vise à
accélérer la fin des régimes spéciaux un
amendement qui n'a pas été retenu dans
le texte final dans le vote final du
gouvernement la droite a donc deux
options soit elle le défend soit elle le
retire mais si elle le retire ça fait
tomber des factos des dizaines
d'amendements déposés par la gauche qui
lui sont liés évidemment ça inquiète un
peu la gauche écouter
quel est en fin de compte l'amendement
visé par l'article 44-3 de quel
amendement le gouvernement ne veut pas
c'est probablement celui de Monsieur
Retailleau nous verrons tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs s'il est maintenu pas
maintenu ce que le gouvernement fera et
en fin de compte ça vous arrange bien
qu'on soit là parce que ça vous permet
de faire croire aux Français que c'est
nous la gauche qui vous avons poussé au
44-3 alors que ceci n'est qu'une affaire
entre le gouvernement et la droite la
plus dure à l'encontre des salariés
celles qui vont mettre fin aujourd'hui
au régime spéciaux en coulisses Quentin
on parle d'un possible votre final
demain midi merci Audrey pour toutes ces
explications et ce récit de ce qui s'est
joué ce matin je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez lire les analyses les analyses de
nos journalistes sur public sénat.fr
merci à toutes les équipes techniques et
éditoriales qui permettent ce grand
direct que vous suivez sur Public Sénat
ce grand direct qui revient à 14h30 je
serai en compagnie de Mathias arez je
remercie donc Audrey vêtas de m'avoir
accompagné toute la matinée très belle
suite des programmes sur Public Sénat
[Musique]